all right thank you and uh thank you for
your patience and apologies for the the
late start so good evening and welcome
to this extraordinary meeting of the
planning committee and welcome to those
watching online if the firearm is fire
alarm is activated please vacate the
offices via the stairs either through
the security door to the right of myself
or opposite the lifts in the foyer
please do not use the lifts please
assemble in hly square on the green and
officers will assist you and advise when
it is deemed safe to return to the
chamber does anyone intend to film the
meeting no I would advise that speakers
using the microphones are picked up by
the cameras recording the meeting so
members of of the public in the public
Gallery behind the speakers may be
picked up by those cameras and have
their image captured any member of the
public who objects to the possibility of
being filmed may wish to take this
opportunity to move or leave the
meeting would everyone pleas present
please ensure their mobile phones are
turned to silent and that they are not
used to make or receive phone calls or
messages in the chamber whilst this
meeting is in
progress I have the following members
who wish to speak under Council rule
procedure 20.1 one um item 3D councilor
Davis and councelor green item 3A
councelor Davis and councelor Rogers
would any other member who wishes to
speak under Council procedure rule 20.1
please announce it
now no thank you the following
applications have been reserved for
public speaking item 3D little Cliff end
farm Chalk Hill Ramsgate item 3A Land
South of Canterbury Road West Ramsgate
item 3B Garage block rear of 161 to 213
Clem Road Ramsgate and item 3 C site of
the former DNE Valley arms Dane Valley
Road
Margate I have apologies from councelor
Wing substituted by councelor mun from
councelor raten substituted by councelor
towning are there any other
apologies and are there any Declarations
of
Interest I have one
yes thank you chair I just want want to
make sure that um the 3C danne Valley
arms I'm award counselor in danne Valley
Ward and I just wondered if that could
cause any problem no that that's
absolutely fine it comes it happens to
all of us that at some point um items in
our own W it that doesn't that alone
doesn't count thank
you um I now have a point of information
I'm going to hand over to Mr
Livingstone thank thank you chair and
good evening members um first point of
information is uh item 3D uh a04 little
Cliffs and farm Chalk Hill uh we'll take
that item first so it's four in the
agenda as members will be aware it's
been deferred from the meeting last week
so we're going to take that item first
in that um then I have a few points of
information um the main
one is that uh the government today
published the revi both the revised uh
mppf and the 2022 result of the housing
delivery test so the update to the mppf
removes the requirement for a 5-year
supply of housing land to be
demonstrated by authorities with a local
plan of less that's less than 5 years
old uh which applies to thanet however
the 2022 results of the housing delivery
test which looks at the completions uh
for three years up until the 31st of
March 2022 looks at the requirement in
the local plan for the delivery of
housing factoring in a discount for
covid um shows that the council's
delivered sorry this shows that the
district has delivered 71% of the
housing need in that period so this
means that the Tilted balance outlined
in the new paragraph 11 of the mppf
would be engaged for any decision that
the council issues tomorrow on the
applications for housing that's being
discussed tonight uh so therefore for
items 3 a 3B and 3 C all of which are
housing the council should uh Grant
permission unless any adverse impact of
doing so would significantly in
demonstrably outweigh the benefits When
assessed against the policies of the
mppf taken as a whole and therefore the
recommendation for those items is not
updated following the changes to the
mppf
today um in uh another update um on item
3A which is um the land south of Canter
Road West Ramsgate um there's um an
error in the the conclusion at the end
of the report outlines a recommendation
um which isn't reflected at the top of
the report above the conditions so I
just want to read out just to confirm
what the motion is uh the or the sorry
the recommendation is the officers are
putting forward so the recommendation is
to defer and delegate the application
for approval subject the receipt of a
legal agreement to secure the outlined
heads of terms and safeguarding
conditions
uh with the um adoption of the Shadow
appropriate assessment uh at Annex 5 as
the recommendation just to confirm
that's in the conclusion of the report
but it's not at the top of the report so
just to confirm exactly uh what the
recommendation is of officers uh and
then regarding item 3 C of danne Valley
arms so condition seven on the
application as stated in the agenda pack
requires a verification report prior to
the commencement of development
following uh Works carried out in a
detailed remediation scheme uh being
carried out to remove unacceptable risks
to human health from contaminated land
so TDC environmental health have
confirmed subsequent to the publishing
of the agenda uh that condition seven
should be worded so that the required
work is carried out prior to the
occupation of the development and with
no requirement for any works if no
contamination is identified within the
submission of a remediation scheme under
the earli
condition six so it's the timing of that
condition that we are updating in the
recommendation so that it doesn't have
to occur prior to the commencement
development has to occur prior to the
occupation and that requirement under
condition seven would not be in Force if
there is no contamination on the site
thank you
chair thank you um any site visits will
take place for committee members on the
morning of Friday the 5th of January
so now we can move on to the um items
that have public speaking item 3D little
Cliffs and farm Chalk Hill
Ramsgate first I have speaking in favor
of the application Mr John elich you
have three
minutes thank you chair and good evening
members it's always challenging to speak
in support of an application when the
item is recommended for approval for
fear of repetition and when officers
have comprehensively addressed all
material planning consider ations and
weigh them in the planning balance in
order to reach their
conclusions i' therefore like to focus
on just two aspects of the submission
one of one of which has been raised by
Third parties namely The partially
retrospective nature of the development
together with the second of what could
be regarded as personal circumstances
not of the applicant but of interested
parties firstly planning guidance
provides for the submission of
retrospective planning applications with
paragraph 12 of the guidance on
enforcements specifically stating that a
local planning Authority can invite a
retrospective planning application if
they consider that an application is the
appropriate way forward to regularize
the
situation it is also accepted in case
law that the planning system and
policies are not punative and the
retrospective nature of any application
doesn't weigh against the
development as members will be aware
from the report the grazing and keeping
of horses has been established upon this
farm for an excess of 20 years with the
applicant successfully achieve an
expansion of this use in June 2021
following an approval of permission
under delegated powers and in the
absence of any third party
representations or objections from any
quarter when the applicants started to
receive requests for grazing facilities
from the owners of horses being kept at
another grazing business in the district
which was due to close it was felt that
a further increase in grazing at little
Cliff S farm was not only essential due
to the predicament of local horse owners
and their animals but which should be
achievable in the light of the previous
approval also and in order to supplement
the relative pity of the local bridleway
network it was considered necessary to
provide additional exercise facilities
in the form of a lunge and or sand scho
the most appropriate location for which
was thought to be to the north of the
existing line of conifers adjoining the
main access into the padic and which
would then be set against the view of
the current planting and development
without impinging upon views of pegwell
Bay when seen from Chalk Hill Canby Road
East and the lord of the
Mana in order to further reduce any
impact upon the landscape and visual
character of the countryside as well as
providing screening around the
facilities to lessen disturbance for
horses from the movement of cars and
commercial and agricultural Vehicles it
was decided to create planted buns
around the facilities which in turn adds
to the biodiversity interests of The
Wider
holding it is therefore hoped that
members will take these important points
into account when weighing the planning
balance for this development which has
received not one letter of objection
from any me member of the public thank
you thank you speaking on behalf of
clien Parish Council councelor Chapman
you have three
minutes thank you chair and counselors
um I'm speaking on behalf of Cliff M
parish and pepo Ward counselor young who
is unable to be here this evening for
personal reasons our objections are not
about the keeping of horses in principle
although we would prefer the site remain
growing crops as it's grade one and
grade 2 agricultural land I'm concerned
about the contamination of our drinking
water of your drinking
water the site is in drinking water
protection zones one and two as
designated by the environment agency
Zone one is the most sensitive Zone
rating there is it has strict
regulations about not contaminating the
groundwater
Supply our concerns are about the
disposal of the horse manure and that is
thousands of tons of horse manure and
contaminated hay and straw per year to
appreciate the scale of this current
estimates of where the horses are kept
are between 40 to 50 stable blocks that
have already been built over an area of
49 Acres currently housing around 120
horses this number of horses alone
produces 800 to 1,000 metric tons of
manure per year and that's likely to
increase as there is no set limit on
this
application the applicant has been
dumping HSE manure onto a Zone one site
close to an aquifer it's even captured
on Google Maps and that is illegal on
two occasions this year the environment
agency has had cause to instruct the the
applicant to remove it on the most
recent occasion he was witnessed
literally bulldozing it into the Zone
one field which is also against the
law therefore we maintain that the
applicant must produce details of how he
will dispose of thousands of tons of
manure legally to the satisfaction of
the environment agency he has not done
so furthermore a necessary condition
must also be that contamination testing
is scheduled to be carried out at
defined regular intervals again to the
satisfaction of the EA and TDC
Environmental
Health in short we must ensure we
believe that thanet residents do not
become ill through drinking contaminated
water let's not repeat what happened at
the aquifers in Margate and in pool Lane
near Westwood cross in recent years they
were both poisoned um with waste
commercial waste and do we really really
want to um to ignore the lessons of
History thank
you thank you um we do need members we
do need to be um careful when
considering when allegations are made
about things that have been happening um
as we cannot take those into account um
next speaking under Council rule 20.1
councelor
Davis thank you chair um with regard to
what you said about allegations I think
it's more than an allegation because if
we check the paperwork in the
application the environment agency
originally actually objected to this
application on the basis that um manure
had been dumped illegally in an adjacent
field that adjacent field is still
having material dumped in it it's been
complained about to uh planning
enforcement we await a response on that
and what's actually happening or what
they say is happening but there is daily
evidence that this field is being used
for dumping manure in a in a uh ground
area zone one um that's a matter of fact
not supposition and I can guarantee that
because we have stood and personally
witnessed
it however um I think there are various
issues on this and as my colleague on my
left has said we don't object to the
keeping of horses however there's some
pretty pretty strange claims here
crump's Farm is mentioned in the
application as the farm that was closed
and why they need additional stabling
for horses if you look back on your own
records of this committee from September
when crump's Farm was approved its seven
houses on a couple of acres and it
clearly states in that application that
the storage units that were going to be
converted to residential were former
Stables so I don't believe that this the
the establishment of this site has
anything to do whatsoever with Crump
stor and it's just a convenient claim
what concerns us is the there is no
limit on what goes on there there is
mention of 40 horses which again we can
then perhaps look at a defined uh amount
of manure and how that would affect the
aquifers but again and I would reiterate
we have two aquifers so far in fact
three because there's another one that's
shut down at the moment if you check
with Southern water and it's all to do
with ground
contamination in order for this to be
approved I believe there need to be um
some very real conditions applied to it
including the management of the manure
where it is stored how it is stored and
that and and we need proper monitoring
to ensure that the environment agencies
rules are adhered to here because
they've been played fast and loose with
in the past I believe there was an error
in the previous approval of horses
because I from memory there is a
reference to dumping manure in the field
across the road which I believe was put
in by an officer um that is an illegal
act because it's a Zone one groundwater
Source the the environment agency
objected to this on that basis they have
withdrawn their their objection but it
is subject to a lot of conditions and
these conditions need to be written into
this permission if it's
granted
um the other issue are the buns sp26 in
the local plan clearly states that the
views across pegwell are to be
unencumbered and they're specially
protected along with other areas on this
island there's already a bond built
there which is blocking partly the view
of the sea across the fields um if you
don't believe me go and have a look with
a site visit the application is
basically to build all these buns and
destroy the open views that flies
directly in the face of the local plan
and
sp26 uh I think I've said quite a lot
and I'll I need to stop you there thank
you ch um I did have councelor green
speaking under rule 20.1 um he's not
present uh I'm going to to hand over to
the planning applications manager who I
believe will come back to you on some of
the points you've
raised thank you
chair uh so the application is a um is a
part retrospective application for the
change of use of agricultural land for
the keeping of horses formation of
access routes sand School lunge parking
areas and bonds so the main issues for
members to consider are the principle of
development the the impact on the
countryside and agricultural land the
impact on the character appearance of
the area specifically the landscape
character area the impact on the
environment and also on highways safety
so the site is outlined here in red um
so you can see the uh little cliffsend
farm en enclosure of buildings at the
bottom of the drawing there you can see
um the main sandwich road on the left
hand side and if we look at
the aerial image you can see Chalk Hill
uh running along um east to west the top
uh so this is an image um from um
probably a bit more than a year ago from
Google which shows the existing
operation of um of of the keeping of
horses are to the east of the little
clef Farm uh set
buildings so this is a block plan of the
um the actual um proposal itself I'm
showing this for context just because uh
to understand the views of the site
members need to understand the proposal
now in the vast majority of of works
that are being applied for have actually
been carried out so these photos which
were taken a month ago will Show members
uh the impact of the vast majority of
the
development so first of all're going to
look at view from the
a299 so we are very much at the North
near the the lord of the Mana roundabout
um so the top of the image that you've
got there so the conifers that you can
see in the middle of the image there
where the mouse is circling is the
little cliffsend farm site um mentions
been made of a of a Bund um which is
this area here so on the left hand side
so this isn't on the application side
it's not part of the application um so
it's not one of the buns that's being
applied
for uh then looking from sandwich Road
um so specifically looking uh just next
to sandwich road so going up so Chalk
Hill Junction is um in the distance and
you can see the the foot paath that runs
up so again that uh Bank of conifers
that's surrounding the little Cliff farm
buildings are on the right hand side of
the image
here and then moving up and this is an
image from Google directly to just show
The Junction the existing access on um
for Chalk Hill on sandwich road so this
is the access that's currently used by
all of the businesses that occupy the
development in around little cliff C
Farm um and then we're going to have a
little look inside the site so for the
proposal itself I mentioned about the
works that been carried out so U the
access trackways have been built so if
we are in at the first Junction of the
the tracks and we're looking down down
the long length of the track and you'll
you'll see this image here you've got um
fences that have been put up already and
the horses that are in situ so this is
the route that goes all the way
basically west to east down the site if
we turn to the right to look towards and
you can see actually on the right hand
side of the image here you can see the
bank of conifers I mention surrounding
little Cliff sand Farm um so if we turn
then and we're looking north to south uh
looking down the route that currently
takes you to the little Cliff Farm site
so you can see here um one of the buns
that's the subject of the application um
running along here and then going down
there and then turning back and looking
back towards where that photo was taken
you can see the change in level that
occurs as you go down towards the little
cliff and farm site and you can see
those um the the field shelters and the
boundary treatments that have been
erected that we were just standing next
to so looking at the detail of uh the
arrangement uh to the just the north of
the little CLI Farm site so you have a
vehicle parking area which is proposed
on the west of this part of the
development uh then you have buns
surrounding that and surrounding the the
lunge uh and then you have the the sand
score itself and another access trackway
there you have a buns that runs East to
uh West and then you've actually got
just outside the red line you've got the
access road that runs to the other uh um
keeping of horses sort of paddocks um
which have already got permission and
are in place so this is a view um so you
can see again there's the little Cliff
sand site Farm site you can see the
parking area which was under
construction at the time of the photo
being
taken then looking um in the middle of
this site looking towards the the lunge
you have the view here so you can see
the um buns themselves have been
formed uh around the the lunge and then
turning to the right from that so we're
looking to the north so you can see
there's the trackway going up to the um
the the paddock and then you've got the
sand school and the enclosure around the
sand school on the right hand side of
the image and then turning to the right
again so we're actually outside the site
the red line site so this is the access
that goes down towards the other uh
element of the site which is the keeping
forces which as mentioned was granted a
proor a few years ago
and then again the conifers on the right
hand side that you can see
there uh and then turning back so again
conif is now on the left hand side so
just again showing the axis way so you
can again see that already some planting
has occurred on the Bund that's been
formed on the right hand side and then
obviously you've got the other BND on
the further to the to the right which is
to the north of the
sign so then just looking at the views
across from Chalk Hill which is um all
the areas that we're looking at we were
just looking at are not publicly
accessible but obviously we really need
to look at the views across the
landscape from Chalk
Hill so here is uh the view looking down
again we're we're in Chalk Hill now
we're looking down towards those
conifers uh as mentioned so that's where
the uh the buns are in front of and then
looking at a bit more of a a close in
view so you can see from looking at this
image you have the the Buns themselves
that form part of the application uh
along just below the conifers there
and then turning to the left just so you
can see um then you've got the the view
of the expanse at the moment across the
fields so as I mentioned the one of the
main considerations the principle of
development so this is covered in page
79 of the Agenda Report so um policy SP
24 for development in the countryside
it's officers views that this is
considered to be the growth um or
expansion of an existing rural business
and therefore it is considered to be in
accordance with policy SP 24 H in terms
of the impact on uh agricultural land um
the land is best and most versatile
agricultural land and policy e16 uh
requires that um that we shouldn't be in
a position to Grant a major development
resulting in the loss of best of most
firsto unless specific criteria is met
now the vast majority of this
development is not irreversible loss of
agricultural land it's only the very
small amount um arguably of the parking
area so it doesn't constitute major
development to be contrary to that
policy uh that is you know it's it's
reversible development and therefore we
consider that it is acceptable in
principle in terms of the impact on the
landscape character area SP 26 uh it's
within one of the landscape character
areas that want some North Shores uh the
main principles and characteristics that
are covered under the survey uh in want
to ensure that there are that
development avoids Skyline um in
intrusion uh to ensure that long
uninterrupted views um and a flat
landscape are maintained uh it is
considered that the development would
not compromise those characteristics
you've seen obviously the views in and
around especially given the sighting
adjacent to the existing site of uh the
development within the countryside at
little kend farm um in terms of the the
field shelters themselves they are all
um obviously single story structures um
so without needing planning permission
you can erect field shelters as long as
uh they meet the tests of operational
development whether they are permanently
attached to the ground um and you and
how they are attached to the ground um
and we don't consider that um from the
views that have been taken at the moment
that the develop those developments them
in of themselves need planning
permission but obiously are they are
part and parcel with the use so you have
got that sort of development within this
uh you know within this this use that's
that's being put forward so in terms of
the impact of the environment as
identified um initially uh the
environment agency uh objected and
raised concerns with regards to um the
location of um a vast majority of the
site or well sorry not the vast majority
of the site but a large amount of the
site um is covered under Source
protection Zone one it's also in a nitr
nitrate V vulnerable Zone um specific
this has been looked at and discussed
with the EA and you'll see from the
discussion on paragraph oh sorry on page
75 um the the further comments that
we've received from the environment
agency um have considered that the
additional information about how the
manure will be spread across the fields
and not stored on Source protection Zone
one uh satisfactory um deals with the
concerns raised and therefore and I'm
going to quote what the environment
agency have stated which is on on page
um that subject to a one planning
condition uh they withdrew their
objection specifically that condition
requires that during the development and
contamination not previously identified
found to be present um should be the
basically the development should be
ceased uh and a remediation strategy
should be carried out in in accordance
with advice from the local planning
Authority uh and until that um
remediation strategy has been submitted
approved and then subsequently
implemented development shouldn't
continue uh specifically though U with
regards to the concerns that have been
raised there is an informative that's
proposed to be put on the application um
and this is um again outlined in the
environment agency's comment um which
basically outlines that manure um if it
is stored in Source protection Zone one
it's got to be it's got to be stored uh
on an impermeable base and with sealed
drainage there can't be any temporary
storage of manure on those areas um and
effectively that temporary storage can
occur on the source protection zones 2
and three but not on Zone one uh this is
specifically um discussed on page 85 of
the committee report um and obviously as
the lead Authority on the matter the
environment agency have not required the
local planning authority to condition
the location of storage but they ask for
the informative to be added now now the
environment agency themselves have
various powers in the event that um
manure for example in this instance is
stored in Source protection Zone one and
indeed they have been in contact with
the applicant on an ongoing basis so it
is considered that by putting on the
informative and and knowing and noting
that the environment agency themselves
have powers under their own legislation
for any issues to be dealt with that
this is adequate as stated in the
recommendation with the informatives and
the unsuspected contamination condition
so picking up a couple of the other
points that are raised in the uh
responses that we received uh it's
considered that development would result
in sufficient parking to be provided no
objection has now been raised by
highways so this is update since the
publishing of the report we have
received a comment from KCC raising no
objection that's been published on the
online portal um it's obviously that
access that I showed you earlier onto
chalk kill is currently in use by all of
the the businesses that are working on
little Ken farm so it isn't considered
that that is an unsafe Junction uh and
that there is parking available on site
um I think the estimate that's been
given is about 20 cars with horse boxes
but obviously there is um there are
various times when that would occur it's
unlikely to be that they're all there at
the same time because the way that the
horses are kept so there are two other
conditions that I just want to mention
to members one is that um obviously
there would be a concern if there was
lighting erected in around the s school
that hasn't currently been submitted to
us uh because of the potential for
Skyline you know intrusion um and light
pollution and therefore there is a
condition which would require that if
there are is any lighting to be erected
that that has to be first submitted to
the local planning Authority prior to
its uh its installation uh and in
addition condition five outlines that
within 12 weeks the date of any approval
a landscaping plan must be submitted uh
which should demonst State um basically
planting on the earth buns with a
species uh a species Rich of grassland
mix and also providing details of how
they're going to be established and the
management of them uh so overall it is
considered that the application would
Accord with the policies of the local
plan and therefore they it is
recommended for approval thank you
chair thank you
um I move that the chair's officer's
recommendation is adopted would the vice
chair please second seconded and uh
before I go into the debate and I do
have a couple of um uh people who want
to speak we're just going to take a
short break for a discussion up here
thank
you
e
um councelor Garner and councelor muns
would you come to the um front bench
please
e
for
thank you members um my our apologies
for that uh it turns out that Council Ms
is not able to um remain as a voting
member of the committee because he's not
on the official Reserve list um we will
be sorting that out at the next full
Council but uh that's the the cause for
the uh the pause in uh the proceedings
um if everyone's ready we'll now move on
to the debate has the motion moved
yes I've just been asked to remind you
that we did move the motion and it was
seconded and everyone
agreed yes thank you um so I first
speaking I've got councelor
Alburn talk me about surpris there chair
I didn't think I was the first one
um Have you listened to the previous uh
previous speakers
um I do have some concerns and and um I
I I think the matter about the um the
effects of the uh of the water system
there is uh a considerable cons
consideration that that we must take
very
seriously um and I'm just surprised that
the environment agency had o overturn
their uh their in initial view
however um there's obviously been a lot
of engineering Works taking place there
car park if we're talking as Mr
Livingston said of 20 vehicles or maybe
all Boxes Etc
Etc um this is a major this this is a
this is going to have a major effects on
that piece of land there
um I think as well looking at the the
conditions and
especially condition
two um
about the
contamination
um there is no condition uh following on
from the
contamination of horse manure Etc and
what the applicant will do with it
um I'm just taking up a point I think
councelor Davis made uh about there
being
sorry yeah U just take up with what
councelor Davis had said there is no
restriction on the amount of
horses and uh looking at the looking at
the
previous uh looking at one of the first
pictures that you put up showing the
view looking
down from an aerial
view which that isn't thank
you as you say you could see uh where
the the current uh use of the horses on
those lands is completely uh are no
longer green if effectively so depending
on how many horses that you're going to
have on
there um you
know I don't think there's enough land
for let say I'm putting 40 horses on
there for instance um
and they're just some of the concerns
that I that I have and I just think it's
it has change it is changing the
landscape of of that part of Cliff
Cliff's end and um I I have concerns
about this thank you o that one um just
just one thing obviously yeah absolutely
right there's no restriction on the
number of Horses by virtue of uh
condition or indeed as part of the
submission it's worth noting that there
are
there are sort of size restrictions
which come from basically Animal Welfare
in terms of how many you can keep in a
in a Paddon horse um but in terms of the
actual extent of covering covering that
area with paddocks obviously that is
what is potentially proposed and as you
can see it's you know sorry the reason I
I skipped onto this one is because
obviously this is showing obviously what
it what it is like at the moment um so
it is something that obviously is is
proposed in there in terms of the the
character of the the fact that it was
obviously
previously a field um obviously the
actual important point about the
character of the area here is the
landscape character area and those views
that you'd get which is why that area is
is designated and obviously on the basis
of the the small scale structures that
are there and present in our view it's
not considered to to cause harm to that
and in terms of the manure aspect um you
know what's been submitted to the
environment agency is that the manure
would be spread throughout uh the source
protection zones which is two obviously
the farm holding is over five hectares
of land so it is a large farm holding
that you can spread manure across and
obviously there are lots of there's lots
of agricultural development that's
occurring all around the district um
which obviously where soil and manure is
spread across fields that doesn't
require planning permissioning and of
itself um but obviously that's why in
this instance the environment agency
have been directly involved you know our
our contamination land officer sorry our
Environmental Protection manager has
been in contact directly with the
environment agency over sort of the
ongoing concerns that have been raised
by residents and it is and it is being
managed both by in terms of the
council's contact with the EA and also
the EA looking into the queries that
have been raised so we do consider that
it's being covered you know by the work
that the environment agency are
doing can I come back CH that's all
right so I I just missed uh one one
point out uh and that is in relation to
con condition two
um for submission of
details
uh as the business is
already commencing is already started
and is already happening um is is there
a a restriction on time for them to
submit the required details only it
doesn't say in in condition two
so it it's specifically it's the we'd
refer to as the unsuspected
contamination condition so it's that
whilst during development if any source
of contamination is found then a
remediation strategy is required so
obviously this is part retrospective and
obviously the work that's still being
carried out to form the parking area and
those areas is what the environment
agency specifically have targeted and
looked at in this
instance uh councelor
bayford thank you chair thank you for
the report um yeah I personally feel
this is is a perfectly acceptable change
of use but I do think that the concerns
raised by our speakers tonight are very
serious ones um I not going over the
same ground again I know but I feel that
the um requirements laid down by the uh
environment agency need to be carefully
monitored um is this any any way any
anything that can be written in to
ensure that this is carried out because
I do think it's very important and I
think um you know the welfare of of of
our residents is is at risk thank
you um come back we'll come back on that
in a moment councelor
Kean thank you um firstly someone just
explained to me what the purpose of the
buns are and I noticed that um there's
it gives the height measurements and
their 3 m but could they be higher if
someone decided to build them higher
that's just my first
part um I must I can't speak to the
purpose of the Buns other than to
enclose those areas um that in terms of
the height it's there's a condition
requiring the development to you know
occur in accordance with the plans and
the plans include the measurements so
that's that's the condition that
restricts it okay and then also and you
sort of uh referred to this in in one of
your previous comments
but it sounds like we can't limit the
number of horses that can be kept there
and yet that would also affect the
amount of manure produced I know you
said about Animal Welfare standards but
um
because the manure affects things then
where does planning stand for
that um so in in terms of the
justification for a condition to
restrict the number of horses in and of
itself there's no additional landscape
and visual impact for example that would
justify restricting the number of horses
if it related specifically to the
quantity of manure produced um if
obviously on the Bas is the as long as
the applicant disposes of that in
accordance with environmental um sorry
in accordance with the environment
agency's regulations then there is no
reason to restrict the number of horses
because as long as they are according
with the separate legislation then
there's no rationale for us to restrict
it on planning grounds alone it
obviously does as you say it does
require them to adhere to environmental
the environment agency's regulations and
to pick up the points that's been raised
about the the monitoring of that we have
you know through the concerns that have
been raised by residents it has been
raised uh a lot and the environment
agency have been involved for the at
least the last six months in looking at
this site and other sites in and around
there um but they have also been in
contact with the applicant uh and
engaging with the the applicant about
the issue so in terms of you know where
where we are now is that the environment
agency are satisfied with the
arrangements that are in place um and if
they weren't they would be bble to take
action and instruct that the operations
that are occurring on site either a
license would need to be submitted um
sorry permit need to be submitted if
there was going to be any storage on
Source protection Zone one but that's
not the intention uh it just needs to be
accorded with in terms of uh the spread
across the source protection zones two
and three um so again on the basis of
the legislation that the environment
agency are looking at we are confident
in and of itself that the planning
permission if if granted would not
result in uh an identified harm to
groundwater um by virtue of the controls
that are in place by the
EA thank you I have councelor Moore next
please yes thank you chairman thank you
Ian for that presentation um my my main
concern is what all the other members
have already muted um which is the
contamination to the aquifers and the
water source for us and it's very
disappointing to see that the E EA um
have been there repeatedly trying to
sort this out with the applicant um
which tells me the applicant reoffends
and keeps doing it which is worrying um
and I think the local Authority should
take the high ground and ask the EA to
take a higher interest in this to
protect the aquifers and the water I'm
got no problem with what the applicant's
trying to do um it complies with all the
legislation as you rightly say um but
the main concern is the contamination
the acers and how we as a local
Authority protect our residents which we
we should be doing regardless and if we
have to keep going on at the EA to do
that then so be it but we need to do
something to protect that as a local
Authority thank
you thank you chair um just to come back
I think it's really important that
members are aware that obviously there
are alleg s that have been made it's
really important that members are
considering the merits of this
particular application um and just
taking into account that and
disregarding allegations that are made
they if allegations or anything that's
investigated separately will be dealt
with separately as part of the
environment agencies um legislation uh
or indeed um you know than District
Council um and looking at planning
enforcement side of things but it needs
to be disregarded from the consideration
of this application thank you um I do
have a couple of other speakers lined up
but I'd like to ask a question that
continues on really from um The Mention
Of Council and more um the enforcement
of environment uh agency regulations
you've mentioned uh a couple of times
about the environment agency have got
regulations how are they enforced we we
have our own planning enforcement for
the planning regulations but what about
things that are not directly us um thank
you chair the it's well it's
fundamentally matter for the environment
agency in terms of um you know it can
result in you know your standard
punitive measures of of fines Etc um I
think it's important that the
environment agency like our planning
enforcement would look to regularize the
situation if if there is something
that's found that's that's contravening
regulations for example the storage of
manure on Source protection Zone one um
to actually Remedy the problem by
removing it is obviously the first thing
uh but in terms of the actual
enforcement Powers I'm afraid I don't
know the exact sort you know the exact
you know quantity of fine all that side
of things of of what could be done it is
a matter entirely for the
EA so it's out of our
control okay thank you uh councelor
Matas thank you chair um to pick up C
keen on the Buns one assumes they're
there for landscaping but also wind
protection because it's obviously open
to the Sea the highest is 3 m and the
lowest is 2 m but they're not a
continuing thing so they don't actually
complete block The View they're there
and it states quite clearly they must be
sewn with species Rich grass land mix so
they're not going to be trees on the top
of them um I can't personally see a
problem with that I've got a couple of
quick questions it quite clearly states
in here in the informatives that they
can't store any manure within protection
Zone one it states that quite clearly
two and three apparently it's okay and
my final question um do we know how many
horses are currently there I know it's
been said we can't can't actually impose
a limit but it gives a rough idea of how
much more this applicant is trying to
add to what he's already
got for a while well I'm afraid I I I
don't have the information on
that councelor
driver yeah yes I I would just like to
actually point out um to members that
that she um in fact actually the Dogman
is actually quite um toxic but actually
cow would actually hold manure it is um
toxic but they
eat they so eat grass so therefore it's
um not a
major thing and that's it
really thank you do I have any other
speakers in that case uh
we living as a do near Elwood farm at
North at North forland there are horses
there I don't know how many there's
probably about 30 or 40 there and they
are not kept in one field all the time
they rotate them from one field to the
other field and then plant that one
would these horses be on that land all
the time in where they are are there is
there any intention to move them around
to other areas or are they all going to
be in the fenced off bit do we know
that um so the the I go back well uh
let's go back to the red line plan quite
a lot land
there yeah be moved from one site to the
other presumably depending how the
grasses yeah so the the the red line
effectively goes round down Chalk Hill
all the way around in that sort of
downwards L shape um so I mean
technically they can be moved around
obviously they've been demarked as you
can see from the photos at the
moment
okay councelor
bright yeah just really really quickly
it's just about the um sort planting on
the Buns um
thinking about hwood Farm um it is and
because the horses are rotated it does
give the fields an opportunity to sort
of grow and sort of re wild if you like
um I'm a little bit concerned looking at
that that it does look very sort of
barren and very sparse um I I know there
is um a condition that they they have to
plant the buns with um grasses and
things um how soon will that planting um
take place
place thank you so the condition
requires the details to come in within
12 months of any approval uh but within
the details it's got to include the time
scales to be agreed basically so um the
aim will obviously be to make sure that
it's planted at the time when it's going
to actually take uh effectively but it's
not mandated by the condition but they
have to provide the details of when they
have to when they would plant
them in that case um we will now put the
motion for the officer's recommendation
for approval to the vote can I have
those in favor
please and
against that's carried in favor thank
you the next item on the agenda is land
south of Canterbury Road West Ramsgate
public speaking speaking in favor of the
application Mr Dan narowski you have
three
minutes thank you chair and good evening
everyone after more than two years of
consultation with and positive
engagement with your officers and other
key stakeholders this application
represents a positive opportunity for
the people of thanet Monson Holmes is
ready to deliver 141 high quality and
sustainable new homes key infrastructure
and almost 2.5 million pound worth of
investment to support and improve
existing Community facilities the site
is located with within a sustainable and
accessible location particularly
benefiting from the excellent
connectivity to The Wider area offered
by the newly constructed thanit Parkway
train station the station lies just to
the south of the site and is easily
accessed via the newly dedicated
pedestrian and cycle routs the proposals
will deliver much needed market and
affordable homes to begin to address the
identified needs of the area and provide
a range of dwelling types and sizes to
help young families to grow to help more
elderly residents to downsize and to
help firsttime buyers onto the housing
ladder thereby achieving a mixed and
balanced
Community Monson homes is a wholly owned
subsidiary of town and country housing
who are themselves a registered provider
therefore we want to deliver as many
affordable homes as possible it's what
we do and do well as evidenced here in
thanet by our Westwood Acres scheme and
the phase one development directly to
the north of this site unlike the PLC
house builders we will maintain
ownership of the estate as well as the
affordable housing and have invested
interest in making sure the properties
are finished to high quality and are
well managed given the very real
viability challenges faced at this site
as independent independently ver
verified by the council's appointed
Specialists the scheme will deliver 22%
affordable housing this nonetheless
represents a significant positive
contribution towards affordable housing
stock in the village and is a major
benefit of the scheme we agree with your
officer's assessment that the proposals
represent a natural expansion of the
village and would be in keeping with the
typical development pattern of Cliff
sand the attractiveness of the scheme is
further enhanced through the significant
over-provision of open space and green
infrastructure to serve the existing and
new residents as well as delivering bio
biodiversity net gains for for wildlife
this will ensure the proposals sit
comfortably within the policy and
contribute positively towards the
character of the local area the
proposals are te accepted against all
technical matters and will deliver
significant positive benefits to the
community Through local infrastructure
improvements secured through the section
106 Financial contributions as such it
is kindly requested that the committee
recognize the benefits of this scheme
and duly approve this application thank
you for your
time thank you speaking on behalf of
cliffs sen Parish Council councelor
Chapman you have three minutes thank you
chair and members
again um we have some serious concerns
with this planning application regarding
several mppf and TDC policies not being
adhered to plus objections raised by TDC
officers and
counselors the proposed 145 houses are
over and above those identified for
growth in the local plan they are not
included in the additional local plan
developments being built in Cliff end
this application would increase the size
of Cliff's end to over
40% this is how you destroy a rural
Village and contravene policy
h09 and it is on grade one agricultural
land as designated by Natural England
defam
map the TDC strategic planning manager
does not support this application
because cliffsend has quote limited
services that was not considered
suitable for a significant level of
housing page 57 in your 56 in your pack
the inspector's report has considered
the new Parkway station and concluded
that it alone quote does not create a
sustainable location for increased
levels of development
unquote the TDC strategic housing
department also state that this
application cannot be supported because
the developer has reduced the number of
affordable homes from 30% to 22% page 57
in your pack add to this Kemp police
concern that the site does not follow
guidance to addressing designing out
crime page
59 the case officers report acknowledges
that several policies are not adhere to
including just for the record spo1 sp24
ho1 e16
sp26 plus there are infringements of
nppf sections 25 8 9 and 15 we submitted
a full and detailed list of these Plus
photos and maps disappointingly
important sections and photos have been
removed from your packs for some reason
but they are still on the planning
website some of the case officers
approval relies on the developer own
assessments such as their claim that
this will have no significant impact on
the open view across to pegwell Bay to
DOA Straits and Beyond this is protected
under policy 26 and the council's
landscape character area report and the
developer assessment that the
agricultural land is of poor quality
page 64 of your pack so is not so
important we maintain that it's not
appropriate to rely on developer marking
their own homework thank
you thank you speaking under Council
rule 20.1 councelor Rogers you have
three
minutes thank you chairman and members I
would like to H light the serious safety
risk and lack of appropriate s106
mitigation for Cliff's end F's Hill is
the only road that connects the north of
the village to the South it's a single
track very narrow with a downhill
gradient from the level
crossing and has no foot paath or Verge
all the amenities are in the South The
Village Hall play area sports field and
Cafe Bar an additional 145 houses in the
north of the village would result in
many more people and much more traffic
using F's Hill the only other access to
the south of the village is through a
field and an alley totally unsuitable
for push chairs wheelchairs disabled
people and people walking
alone the appropriate mitigation would
be to build a footpath for approximately
135 M there is space to do so the case
officer's report States this is not
achievable because the applicant is not
the land owner this is not a valid
reason for rejection clion Parish
Council and the residents believe that
the council has the duty of care to
properly consider this the case officer
acknowledges that no assessment of
community facilities have been carried
out as stated on page
98 and although cliffan Parish Council
was not consulted on this initially they
proactively submitted appropriate
requirements in accordance with the mppf
all those requirements have been
rejected without proper dialogue apart
from the £10,000 towards building
disabled toilets which falls short even
for that the fin Financial contributions
to go outside Cliffs end total 2 million
this is out of all proportion not in
line with the pp
nppf there's no doctor's surgery dentist
or shops in cliffsend apart from the
garage on sandwich Road there's no
amenities to the north of cliffsend if a
site visit could be arranged it would
highlight our safety concerns regarding
fo's Hill thank
you thank you and also speaking under
Council rule 20.1 councelor Davis
thank you chair um I think my colleagues
either side have raised most of the
points uh extremely well um however I'd
like to just highlight a couple of
factors and particularly the fact that
cliffsend is a village of two halves
separated by a single track Lane with no
pedestrian facilities no lighting or
anything and it's a death trap um and
for an officer to say that because the
the land adjacent to the road isn't
owned by the applicant so it's not
relevant is
frankly amuses me however um there are
mitigations and I think uh firstly I
think we should not be building on
agricultural land and we know that I'm
very uh pleased to hear uh the home SE
Secretary of State's uh decision today
to remove the 5-year land Supply
requirement because that I believe is
our major vulnerability locally because
of the fact that our local plan is
sitting in OB bance for an update
um however um if that requirement is no
longer there then we I believe have a
duty to our residents and so on to look
at the cost to the residents relative to
the risk of whether it went to appeal by
being denied I don't think this is
necessary it's not in the local plan
it's not allocated land it does not
comply I mean why are we down to 20 22%
affordable when it's our policy is 30 %
and phase one because it didn't sell has
gone 100% affordable and is not yet
occupied so why are we dropping it to
22% on phase two doesn't make any sense
there's there is a uh an issue in that
Cliffs end needs to be more sustainable
but it needs to be one Village because
there's a shop due application in to
build a shop in the south side of the
village that doesn't help these the top
end of the village and put in another
couple of hundred people there is simply
going to isolate them there's no public
transport facilities that are worth
speaking of unless you traes across the
field to the to the parkway station but
the bus services have been cut back the
village is isolated and putting people
out there whether in affordable homes or
not is not going to it's not sustainable
it's not viable at the moment I've lived
in Cliff's end and sustainability was a
long-term issue so yes it needs so it
needs to grow in a sustainable way but
not in a way that puts hundreds of
people's lives at risk um and uh and
divides the village basically um the
strategic planning manager doesn't see
any need for this um I've got a couple
of other questions I'd like to know why
the members pack the briefing pack was
edited and some very relevant
information including the errors and and
emissions from the mppf wasn't provided
to them because it might be sitting on
the website but wasn't in the briefing
pack and I'm damn sure that every member
of this committee looks at a briefing
pack rather than referring to the
website questions gor I'll finish at
that but I don't think this is necessary
thank you I am now asking the planning
principal planning officer to outline
the
report thank you chair this is the
application site here so outlined in red
on this plan um so we have the um a 299
to the west and south of the site um Can
Road West to the north of the site and
um uh Clive road on the right hand side
here and then you can see the area
outlined in blue is in the same
ownership as the applicant and this has
um recently um been constructed as a as
a new Housing
Development so this is um just showing
you the um local plan and the
allocations for the village so current
ly the um sites you can see um
highlighted in in um Brown are the
allocated housing sites within the
village so the areas to the south of the
Village um have both had permission and
been
constructed and then this area here is
the area um owned by the applicant which
has just recently been constructed as
well but not yet occupied and then north
of the um cry Road West is the gench
site which has had permission but has
not come um forward for development and
then the application site itself is in
this location here south of this um
allocation
site so this is just showing um an AAL
view of the Village um the application
site is in this area here you can see
that there's been lot of um um
excavation work for the archaeology so
the area that you can see is is
basically the the outline of the
application so it follows down below the
um the previously approved housing site
and then there's an angled um section
here so all this area that's that's um
excavated is is the application site
so it's um north of the a299 and and as
mentioned it's in the the northern part
of the village which is um divided by
the railway that runs through the
middle so the site isn't allocated in
the in the local plan so the proposal
does um um doesn't comply the objectives
of uh policies ho1 or spo1 which do seek
to um provide housing either within the
confines of um Villages or the urban
area or on allocated housing sites um it
also doesn't comply with um policy sp24
which is the countryside policy um which
doesn't um refer to um Housing
Development and doesn't seek to um
approve housing development in the
country side again unless it's um
allocated but again all of these um
policies are up for assessment and we
need to look at whether the site whether
the harm from the development outweighs
the benefits um and given the fact as I
mentioned at beginning beginning of the
meeting tonight um we we still have to
look at um the M ppf and the fact that
we are still um uh we still have to
outweigh look at whether the um harm
outweighs the benefits When assessing
any site even if it goes against um some
policies we have to look at the app the
local plan as a whole and balance
everything up so in terms of uh
sustainability of the site that has been
mentioned a few times and as you as
heard it has been mentioned by the um
strategic planning manager as well about
concerns regarding the sustainability of
the village when looking at allocations
of um of housing on the on the within
the Village um the provision of Parkway
station which is now open and and in use
will make a big difference to
sustainability in the village so from
the site itself you can easily walk to
um the station within a few minutes um
and therefore that is a big influence
for this application in terms of
improving sustainability for the site
and within the village itself um in
terms of facilities within the Village
um there is an existing Hall and Church
in the southern part of the village and
there's now um a cafe um along sandwich
Road that's recently opened which um is
also a bar I believe um so that there's
that facility in the South um and in
terms of proximity to um the urban area
this is just showing the proximity of
the application site to the urban area
so bottom left of this slide is the
application site and then manston green
development um is in the top um right
hand side here and that's currently
under construction so it's an extan
consent that's currently being built
phase one is being constructed and it
does contain a primary school so in
terms of proximity to facilities that
needs to be a consideration that there
is going to be a primary school in this
location here which potentially is
walking distance of the village once um
these improvements come through and
there will be there's a footpath that
runs along Canby Road West and there
will be scope to
um improve access to to uh the primary
school and to facilities in manston Road
such as the tesos so in terms of
sustainability we do we do feel
sustainab sustainability of the village
is improving there are limited services
within the village at the moment but
there is there is the potential for this
to improve and has improved through the
parkway station provision there's also
the extent consent for a um a retail
unit within the center of the village as
well which again there's a there's a
current application that's pending um
showing the intention of um the
applicant to to try and continue with
that and provide that um service within
the village so that is just a
consideration for members when thinking
about
sustainability um so just to show you
then um some some views of the site and
some photos of of the site itself so um
as I mentioned this is the application
site here so the area where it's shown
as excavated um for the archaeology and
the site to the north is is the site
that's recently constructed this area
here was the drainage for that
development but actually would be
included within this application site
and then drainage um through this scheme
would would also serve that development
as well so this is just a view then from
the East looking towards it so you can
see that the site is is basically
surrounded by um the a299 so there will
be long views into the site from um the
surrounding Motorway um but also you can
see that the site is um um bordered by
existing residential development to the
East and to the north through the new
development then here we're where
Parkway station has been constructed so
you can see in proximity to it there's a
footpath that runs across the bridge and
then straight to the station which as I
mentioned can be walked within minutes
um from the
site so these are some photos now in
inside the application site so this is
taken from the southern boundary looking
North so this photo here you can see the
Housing Development to the north that's
been constructed so that's um um the one
that to the north that's under same
ownership this proposal seeks to follow
the Western um boundary of that built
form so the boundary of this site would
would be approximately here following um
that built form and then everything to
the West that was in the red line is
just open space so housing wouldn't
extend into the open space beyond what's
already constructed to the
north um so again just a closer view of
the houses so through this proposal the
the building types are very similar to
the the units within this scheme so
these ones that you can see are
replicated through through this
application and then a further view this
is a different time of year when the um
the fields have been um uh uh cleared um
and this is showing again from the south
looking up towards the site this area
here you can see was the the drainage
that was being provided so the
application site again would run along
the boundary so where you can see that
far fencing that's the boundary um line
of this application site so includes all
of this area here and this again you can
see the development in the in the
distance this is the um existing foot
path that runs along the um eastern
boundary of the site and then connects
onto the public right of way that runs
along the southern boundary of the site
and then that connects through round to
Parkway so you can see it's a pedestrian
and cycle
link and then again you can see the The
Pedestrian cycle link on the right hand
side and again the application site is
in this location here and now this is
along the southern boundary of the site
so this is the existing public right
away that runs along the southern
boundary you can also see there's um
lots of um Landscaping that exists along
the the southern boundary as well the
land levels across the site change quite
drastically so um to the east of the
site it's higher than the west and the
south of the site is higher than the
North so it's all there's quite a lot of
slopes um along the site so at this
point here is is is higher than the the
area you can see in the in the distance
where um and the boundary of the site is
sort of approximately this level
here now this is the the foot path as it
crosses over the a299 towards Parkway
which is on the left hand side here so
again you can see this is the existing
public rway and now you can see the
vegetation that exists and obviously the
ground level change from the a299 up to
the application site and this is from so
these are some Google images in in
included within this cuz I couldn't stop
um so this is taken now from the 1899
from the southern boundary looking back
towards the s so now you can see the um
development that's been constructed and
again the boundary of this one would
follow the same boundary western
boundary is that
development and then as you go further
along it becomes more hidden by um the
The Verge and the Landscaping that
exists um along the southern boundary
this is taken from the other side of the
road so next to Parkway station looking
back towards the application site so
again on the left hand side um you can
see the existing houses again
and then so this is we are now showing
you from this location here where
Parkway is across towards um the site
here and then so this is now in Parkway
station again looking across so Parkway
and the site itself a similar level but
then the road is is lower so you will
get more views of the the site from the
station but less from um the road to the
South and then again a further view from
Parkway station looking towards the site
so from in terms of views from the south
from this level um in terms of the
impact obiously there the backdrop of
the existing houses from this view so
there's there's no um particular impact
in terms of long-distance views from
from this particular level because that
the impact won't be much different to
what you would get from the existing
development that exists there and then
these are just a few FS show in Parkway
station and how um later on I I'll
discuss the public right of way and how
this can how a new public Right Way um
and improvements of the public right way
will help to provide a footpath links
through the Village from north to south
but this is just showing the um public V
way uh sorry The Pedestrian link once it
gets into the station and then on the
right hand side here um is this is the
one of the allocation housing sites I
showed you in the allocation slide so
this is the north of cotton Road Site um
and a public right of way or pedestrian
link would continue through from here to
that development and down to um coton
road so just showing you that view so in
terms of from the West this is the West
looking towards the application site
which is again in this location here so
Road level there's again Landscaping
along the the boundary of the site from
this point the the development is quite
far away so there'll be quite um minimal
views really from this distance because
you've got quite a lot of open space
before you reach it and then taken from
the north so from cry Road West looking
back down towards the application site
there's a few um views here so this is
taken so can Road West is on the left
Town side here you can see it's quite
small but you can see the housing
development in this location here and
then the proposal would be in this
location here again following that same
line so in terms of the landscape
character area we we've had the um
landscape character um impact assessment
submitted um and it has looked at the
impact from views from from all around
the site um one of the main issues is
whether there's going to be an impact on
the views of Peg Bay which you can see
is in the distance here but there given
the fact there's quite a lot of veget
ation and the ground then slopes down um
and again given the presence of the
existing development here it is felt
that that in terms of longdistance views
there would be quite um the backdrop
would reduce the impact from the
vegetation and from the existing built
form that exists in the village and
again the the development is not
extending into this open space here so
from the north there's very limited
views going um South because the
development already exists to the north
of the site so again this is now from c
r again just for just closer to the site
so you've got the um approved
development here and the application
site is just to the rear here and then
again just showing a closer views of of
the
buildings and then again the distance
here so this is now the um access into
the site so this is the existing vehicle
access into the development to the north
this application would use this same
access point so it's just showing that
um that that's present it's um quite a a
wide um access with with visibility onto
can Road West and then just a few photos
showing the development and here you can
really see the ground level change as it
as it drops away from can Road West and
again you can see some of the unit types
as
well um so just to show you then the
impact on neighbors so Clive road is in
this location here and you can see Cliff
View Road in this location here so in
terms of cliffie Road the majority of
the properties are Ang low some of them
have accommodation at um roof level but
they are um mainly single story in
height in Clive Road there's a few more
um larger units so this is in Clive Road
this is the um closest property to the
application site um I'll come back to
this later on but you can see there's
quite a low boundary treatment currently
between um this unit and the site um and
then this is just some examples of
properties that are in clve road you can
see many of them are Bungalows and then
on the south side of Cl Road there are
um a few two story dwellings close to
the site so these two units on the right
hand side are the ones closest to the
development um as well on the other side
of the
road and then this is just showing the
end of cive road so in the plan I show
you this is being provided as an
emergency access into the site this
won't be um a main access at all into
the site other than for for pedestrians
and and cyclists and then the path that
I showed you earlier on the on the
Eastern side of the boundary is this in
this location here so you come along
Clive Road and straight onto that cycle
footpath link running down the eastern
boundary of the
site and then there again you can see
that path um so in terms of looking at
the actual um layout this was the layout
of the approved scheme that's been
constructed so you can see the access
onto C road which runs down here um and
then this proposal joins onto this road
so this is the um proposed layout so you
can see the um north of this slide is is
the approved scheme and then how it
joins on to now this um proposed
development so the layout of the
development is restricted slightly by um
constraints that exist on the site
including
um a gas main that runs through the site
um from um North West to Southeast um
and also a water main that runs along
the eastern boundary of the site as well
which pushes units away from the
neighbors because there's no um ability
to build over this particular area so
that has had some impact on the the
layout of the scheme but otherwise the
um scheme pretty much follows the
pattern of development of the northern
site um with um a road that runs down um
wraps around so there is um a loop road
at the bottom and then a few cold acts
coming off um that main spine Road
through the middle you can see there's a
mix of unit types with with semi-
detached detached and um semi detached
detached and terce units through the
site as well as a flat block which is in
this location here um there's a number
of open space areas within the site so
the bottom left of this slide you can
see a very large um area that's open
space so this area will contain the
drainage for the development so it
contains a number of the infiltration
basins um within this space but this
will also then be provided as a Park
area with a footpath that runs through
and picnic area um and you can see
Landscaping shows that it would be um
screened around it with new tree
planting as well um in this location
here on the right this is the equipped
play area that would be provid ided um
within the site and then there's another
informal play Space to the center here
and then top left there's um a community
um garden with growing area with a a
shed and other facilities um for the for
the residents um and to the right hand
side of the equipped play Space is also
um an orchard as well so just a closer
view of this just so you can see it so
top left is is that community space and
then the informal space um and then the
southern part again just showing the um
Open Spaces in this location and then
the flat block on the right hand
side and then this is just a clear R viw
um just showing those Open Spaces just
um so you can see it because again the
plans are quite small so it's sometimes
difficult to see so this again on the
top right is the um the Park area with
footpath running through and you can see
clearly in this now the the infiltration
basins that exist um under the land um
top left is the um equip play area so
that will will contain things such as a
or the suggested a table tennis court
and a basketball ring and um fitness
equipment so something that differs to
the play area that's already been
provided in the northern scheme which is
um this equipment for smaller children
this would have something for maybe
older children so there's a bit of a
variety across the two sites bottom left
is is the informal play space and then
the bottom right you can just see the
layout of that um community
[Applause]
space
um so on this plan you can also see the
emergency access which is um in this
location here that joins onto Clive road
so they're proposing to um install um
retractable ballards in this location so
it would only be used for emergency
vehicles um and along the southern
boundary of the site you can see that
there's a a landscape buffer proposed
which would also um be provided with an
acoustic fence um in order to um
restrict noise impact from the railway
and the road to future users of of the
development so there's a mix of um house
types within the scheme so the different
colors show the different house types um
all of them are twostory um had
encouraged them to try and include a few
more um Bungalows which would have been
more in keeping with the units that are
present within um C View Road along the
southern boundary these have dropped in
height and these are actually smaller
units which I'll show you later with the
elevation plans but otherwise everything
is is two story with um Pitch roof or
gable
roofs um so these are some elevation
showing the design of the
units so this this first one is um the
two um internal um Street elevations
running through the spine Road through
the middle of the site so you can just
see there so there's quite a lot of
space between units they're not
particularly cramped um on the side
there's quite a lot of space between
them and and these are the semi-
detached and and detach units that you
can
see um then this is showing from Clive
road so the top part of this slide on
the left hand side of the existing
properties in Clive Road this property
here is the flat block that's being um
provided and then um houses beyond that
so there's quite a big gap between the
flat block and the nearest neighboring
properties because this is the location
of that pedestrian cycle link that runs
South along the eastern boundary um in
terms of scale of the units you can see
they because the closest two properties
in Clive Road are two storage Wellings
the actual proposed dwellings don't
actually um differ significantly in
scale to to those units um some
amendments were made to this this flat
block from the original plans just to
try and improve the the design and
increase um interest of of the
elevations but um so this this is the
front elevation bottom left and the side
elevation on the right hand side here
and then this is just another view
showing the entire um Street elevation
from Clive road so again the flat blocks
top left and then you can see the um
houses and again you can really see the
ground level drop as well as you go um
west across the site the bottom part of
the slide is the um northern section of
that road so again the extension from
Clive road going west this is the
northern part of it so again quite a lot
of spacing between the units and
selection of just semi- detached and
detached units there and then this is
the Western Edge so this is probably
this is one of the most important um
elevations because this is the view that
you'd get from the longer views from the
north and from the West looking towards
the EP ation site um so there's one long
elevation on the top here and then I've
tried to break that down in again into
two just to make it slightly longer so
sorry bigger even um so this these two
are the same as the top one but this is
basically showing the entire um Western
elevation that you would get as it drops
down you can again you can really see
the ground level change as it drops down
the site um and you can see it's quite a
lot of space in between the
units there's a mix of some Terrace
units and and then detached and you can
see there's a a variety of um materials
being used including um black cladding
which is is quite a good um material in
longdistance views to avoid um
significant visual
impact and then um these are just a few
slides just showing a few more other
unit types within the scheme so you can
see some of the Terrace units on the top
right um again a variety of different
ones with porches and um different
features to the building and again
another slide shown a few varieties of
those and then this is now along the
southern boundary so there was quite a
lot of disc discussion with the
applicants about this um this boundary
originally it came in with terrorist
units and there was um concern that
because of the views that you would get
from the a299 from the south that that
would um appear too dominant and
wouldn't appear spaciousness spacious
enough um given the fact it's on the
edge of the the the Village um so we
were really Keen to make sure we had
spacing in between the units and also
that the heights of the units would drop
down as low as possible so this is the
um fin Amendment we've had for the units
H Along on that southern boundary which
has dropped the East level down to one
and a half stories um which we feel now
is is appropriate in the in the longer
views from the site and especially given
the fact there's going to be the
acoustic fencing and Landscaping buffer
in front of this um this unit so this is
the street elevation now that we've
we've had from the applicants showing
that so um the a299 um you can see is is
run along here and this was that grass
um Verge that you saw earlier with the
existing landscaping and you can see
that that with the droing height um
these levels now close to the the level
of the top of the Landscaping so all
you'll really see from this view is
going to be the roofs of the unit the
bottom slide is um incorporating the
proposed Landscaping that the applicants
have have recommended so they're
proposing new tree planting along that
southern boundary and the um through the
landscape um impact assessment they've
looked at the impact from the tree
planting over a um construction period
one year period and a 15year period so
the trees down in in on this bottom
slide is showing what would happen over
time as the trees establish so the the
largest tree is basically upon 15 years
of time passing how big the trees would
be and the impact that that would have
to try and reduce the visual impact from
the
south and then these are just some um
images that they've produced to show um
the what they consider would be the
impact from the road level looking up
towards the development with that
additional tree planting that's being
introduced um so in terms of uh building
material this shows the um variety of
materials um being um being proposed so
it includes um a few different red
bricks moldy stocks and some other
bricks and a buff brick as well then
there would be um dark boarding and tile
hanging so it's all quite traditional in
terms of materials um and really the
design of the units which are considered
to be in keeping with um the general
pitch roof design of of properties
within the
village in terms of looking at the
impact on the neighbors um so the main
neighbors affected are are these
neighbors so this is turned around now
so this is the eastern boundary but just
so you can see it in in close detail
these are the Neighbors in Cliff um
Cliffy Road and then Clive Road here so
in terms of the distance from these
properties because of that water main
that runs along the eastern boundary
there's a distance of 30 approximately
33 M from the rear elevation of these
properties to the nearest neighbor
um which is quite important given the
fact that the neighbors are Bungalows
and there's currently not really any
overlooking of their properties so
really it needs to significant see the
21 MERS that we would normally look at
so with 33 MERS we feel that this is is
sufficient to avoid any significant
overlooking in this area here there's um
the play area adjacent to the the
nearest neighboring property in Clive
Road um and as you saw in the photo
earlier which is this photo here um
they've currently got quite a low um
boundary and there was concern raised
from the neighbors regarding sec
security um impact from noise from the
play area um so we've we've looked at
the boundary and um looking we've added
a condition that would achieve an
acoustic fence that runs along the
boundary as well as some um hedge
planting which will help to reduce any
um security concerns and the impact of
noise from this play area being adjacent
to the
neighbor um the other neighbor affected
would be this um property here um to the
south of Clive Road and the closest to
the flat block
um so there's a distance of 21 M from
the side elevation of the flat block to
the side elevation of the neighbor the
only real impact um that we can see is
from a window that's located in this
side elevation here which we look into
the rear Garden um this is this that
property this is their side elevation
and this is the first floor plan of the
flat block which on the right hand side
of this slide at the bottom you can see
is um a lounge window so so was
concerned that that could look into the
neighboring um Gardens so a condition um
is seeking to obscure glaze that window
to avoid any significant overlooking and
all of the other windows are are looking
um side onto the property and wouldn't
actually look into the the private
imunity space of that property so um the
impact on on that neighbor is considered
acceptable as well so it's not
considered there's any any real
significant harm to the neighbors from
from this um this
scheme um in terms of the uh 10e um
proposed so um The Proposal is for 22%
affordable housing on the site a
viability assessment has been submitted
and we have had that independently
reviewed um we've we've gone back and
forth with them looking at looking at
the figures and the those are attached
within the um the annex of of the report
um the conclusion of it is that um the
the assessment shows that 22% is
considered to be a reasonable provision
of of of affordable on site based on the
current costs um of of the site and at
22% the developer would achieve a um
profit of 14 um. 8% I think I remember
reading um which Falls below the um
recommended profit levels within the
mppf so any increase of affordable
housing would take them even lower than
that and that would be unreasonable so
um so in terms of the affordable housing
policy is considered to comply with the
policy because they have carried out the
viability assessment which we um
consider to be um acceptable and
reasonable so in terms of the actual
provision the proposing 31 units of
sorry 31 units of affordable housing
which um is broken up as 65% affordable
rent 32% first homes and 3% shared
ownership um on this plan here you can
see the affordable rent um which we're
always quite Keen to see spread around
the site is it is the yellow so it's the
bottom left the flat Block in this
location here and you can see some units
along the north of the site here as well
um then the first homes of the purple
which again are in this location and
further down here and then there's one
shared ownership along the South here so
it is felt that the the units are are
split um around the site um and in terms
of the tenure that's considered to be
acceptable and and the percentage as
well in terms of the um impact on
highways so as you saw from the photos
earlier the utilizing the existing
access onto cry Road West this just
shows um the tracking within the site
which is is achievable um the applicants
confirmed that all of the roads within
the scheme will be um provided to
adoptable standards um and um tracking
is provided for the 30 m long waste
vehicle which would be a to turn within
the site
um in terms of the impact from the
actual development because it's to the
north of the Village and can Road West
has has been um downgraded there's
there's less impact on that road and
there's capacity at all of the Junctions
that come off can Road West to serve
these additional units um as mentioned
that was the the Link Road was um the
emergency road being provided here would
be conditioned to make sure it's only
used as an emergency road and therefore
Vehicles wouldn't be able to go actually
directly into the center of the village
so everything coming out from the north
of site would is likely to either go
west or east out of the village so there
shouldn't be any real impact on the
actual um center of the village itself
um The Proposal includes 288 parking
spaces and 47 um visitor parking spaces
which um KCC are consider acceptable and
a travel P plan has been um submitted as
well with ways in which to improve um
sustainable transport through the scheme
which um has been conditioned and
includes a monitoring fee for that into
the future as well um in terms of the
public right of way then um so the
existing public right of way runs along
the west and boundary of the site so
whilst I've showed you um photos of the
um Cy pedestrian link on the Eastern
side that's just an additional um
pedestrian link but the formal public
RightWay runs along the western boundary
um adjacent to the northern the northern
development and then um through the
along the western boundary of the site
and then through the actual um
application site itself onto the
southern boundary where the public
RightWay continues so through the
application to the north we secured a
financial contribution towards the
Improvement of um a footpath link that
would help to um link the site to
Parkway um we we have um that money
that's been provided and um KCC public
by away have looked at the the costings
again based on um current um costs and
taking away that contribution that we've
already secured from the development
above there's a requirement for only
4,162 so that's been secured and and
agreed by the applicant through the
application so what that would result in
is money to um resurface the existing
public right of way that runs from Canby
Road West along the western boundary up
to the application site and then through
the application site the applicant is
proposing to widen and resurface the
public right of way until it reaches the
southern um public right of way and then
this would allow um people to continue
walking around to Parkway station and
then through the cotton Road um North
application we secured another Financial
contribution which was to provide um a
footpath link from that site up to
Parkway station so what that will result
in is a full um pedestrian link from
canre Road West all the way through to
cottington road so whilst there have
been um concerns raised by um Clifton
Parish Council and um who are very keen
to see improvements to um fos Hill which
is completely reasonable because it it
it is dangerous I mean I walked along it
myself just to to walk around the site
and there's a real pinch point there as
you go across the railway where you can
only get one car and you can only really
get you know one pedestrian really like
walking along next to it so I can
understand the concerns of the village
in terms of that being um an issue but
it's it's difficult for us to really
secure anything here because the land
isn't owned by um the applicant KCC
haven't raised it as a concern either so
in in some instances where the land
isn't owned by the applicant and also
the land isn't owned by KCC they can
look to try and um secure the land um
but there has to be a reason for it and
in this case casc haven't raised this as
a safety issue they've not raised it as
a concern so we couldn't we couldn't um
look to take the land without there
being a justification for it the other
concern with that as well is that even
if you were to um secure a a footpath
link that extended from the south along
the South um Beyond below the boundary
of the sorry below the station the
railway line
um north of the Railway line there's no
foot path at all along F Lane running
all the way from the the um Railway up
to cany Road West so even if you were to
secure it there you still wouldn't have
a footpath link that extends up to the
north of the village whereas through
this proposal we would have um a um a
resurfaced area that would be able to
serve Wheelchairs and Buggies and
everything else that's needed all the
way from the north to the South so this
is a much safer way of achieving it and
we we can achieve it through this site
so it would then allow people to to go
down to Cotton Road and then from cotton
Road through the new um housing schemes
there there's then a another pedestrian
link through a new footpath provision
that will allow a complete provision
through to the center of the village so
it's considered that that is is
acceptable to improve um Public Safety
um for pedestrians and and and cyclists
as
well um in terms of the Railway Network
ra have requested a financial
contribution towards um improvements at
the station to try and encourage people
to use the station so the proposal
they've put forward is for shelters for
the ticket machines which is £99,000
which the applicant has agreed to as
well so that would um provide um
shelters for the two ticket machines in
the
station in terms of um other costs that
have been um raised so again the Clifton
Parish Council have put a request in for
um Financial contributions which
included the provision of the foot path
and looking to try and um seek Financial
contributions towards the recreation
area and and sports
provision for us to secure the
contributions it has to be reasonable
and it has to be justified and through
the actual application site itself they
are proposing um open spaces so is
expected that any future residents
within the scheme would actually be
using these existing spaces rather than
using the existing spaces within the
village so we have to there has to be a
harm for us to mitigate in order for us
to secure the financial contributions so
for the actual recreational space and
sports provision it's not considered
Justified because they are providing um
Sports provision through their scheme
which would actually serve residents of
the village as well and then um the
recreational space um to the South here
and and the informal space here which
again would um would serve the residents
um which is unlikely to result in them
needing to use the existing facilities
so the only justification we could find
is is to the actual Village Hall so um
clion Parish Council have raised concern
conerns with the fact that there's a
need for improvements to the Village
Hall and the project that identified is
the provision of a disabled um toilet
within the the
hall um we don't have any details of the
cting but um it's not clear whether it's
a reconfiguration of the space but we've
we've taken it to be to be that rather
than the actual extension of the hall
and the applicant has offered £10,000 um
to to carry out those Works to the hall
so that has been offered um and would be
secured through the legal agreement um
to to as a benefit to the
Village um so in terms of just other
points biodiversity um there's there's
no real um habitats that were identified
within the site in terms of like
protected species at all so it was just
really nesting Birds was was the real
issue that was
identified um wintering surveys were
carried out and it it showed that there
um the golden plava which is is one of
the um birds that used the special
protection area don't aren't likely to
have used a site from all the survey
they've carried out they don't use a
site so it's not considered there be um
an impact on functionally linked land
within the special protection area um
through the application they are
proposing new tree planting and hedge
planting and then there's lots of wild
flower provision as well within the open
space um to the left here um as well as
like The Orchards and and other things
so there is there is some biod there are
biodiversity enhancements through the
scheme which would help to um achieve
the habitats for the the nesting
Birds um so overall there are there are
there is some harm because the fact it's
an unallocated site within the village
but it is considered to be sort of a
sustainable location in terms of its
proximity to the railway um the fact
that with the railway within 5 minutes
you can be with Ramsgate cuz I've looked
at the looking at the times you can get
to Ramsgate um 5 minutes and then from
there there's lots of easy access to um
the health center which I believe this
I'm looking to this site we full within
the catchment of the health center so
actually you could get there quite
quickly and and use that facility um the
facility within the village that I've
mentioned and the facts that Manson
Green's going ahead um we consider that
all of those things make this appear
quite a sustainable site and in terms of
the actual location it is quite a
natural expansion to the village where
it's not extending beyond the um
existing western boundary of um existing
development and in terms of the impact
on landscape car area with the backdrop
of existing development and all the
Landscaping that exists along the
southern boundary it's considered that
that um that will help to um reduce any
any real impact so whilst there is the
visual impact harm obviously the benefit
is that the fact we are achieving 141
units it started off as 145 but the it
has dropped to 141 in order to achieve
the the spacing that we were looking for
along that southern boundary so it's now
141 units and of that we are are getting
22% affordable housing so those there
are social and economic benefits from
that provision um and when weighing
those against the harm is considered
that the the benefits in in our view on
balance do outweigh the harm um so the
application is um recommended to be
deferred and dedicated um for approval
subject to the receipt of the legal
agreement which will secure all
Financial contributions as set out
within the report um including the the
contributions to the the hall and the
railway and the public RightWay plus
everything else requested by KCC and um
the ccg and the 22% affordable housing
um and subject to the safeguarding
conditions and the adoption of the
Shadow appropriate assessment in Annex
five thank
you thank you I move that the office's
recommendation is adopted with Vice
chair please second seconded thank you
um first speaking I have councelor
bayford
thank you chair and thank thank you for
the detailed
report I believe that we need
sustainable growth and I feel that a
good range of um dwellings and green
spaces is being proposed and that the
development proposed development is well
planned however um considering that
this um this site is not allocating the
local plan I'm find it quite
disappointing that the affordable
housing um percentage is is is has been
dropped to
22% um I'm wonder whether any
adaptations could be made so that this
could be raised I also wonder whether a
site visit may help us to appreciate the
potential traff traffic issues raised by
our speakers tonight um I don't believe
that the applicant not Lo owning the
land is justifiable re reason to
compromise the safety of our
residents
thank
I'm sorry just to come back on the 22%
Point um because I know this is an issue
that obviously members are very aware of
so we have gone back a couple of times
obviously all the reports are at the in
the annex where our Consultants have
raised issues it's then gone back we've
had a revised assessment appraisal done
and then it's come back in uh with
another report being looked
at um the issue on the site
fundamentally is about um really it's
the the cost of developing the site just
generally in terms of building the
houses and those costs have been looked
at and assessed um add in then the the
the gross development value of the site
in terms of what you'd actually get for
those houses when they sell and there
has been lots of back and forth about
what values you take uh and looking at
the upper range which is what obviously
we are looking to do uh the issue though
when you look at the site is that even
to get
22% U the developer profit on that basis
is um is is the 14.8 now the national
plan policy practice guidance notes
basically say you can look at a range
between 15% and 20% developer profit now
um with the um shaan Road application
which obviously went to a public inquiry
their big argument that was about the
fact that the developer would put
forward 17 a half% so the midpoint
between that guidance uh and in that
instance the the inspector after taking
evidence considered that to be
reasonable because it's within that uh
that that sort of span and in this
instance obviously they're actually
provide you know their appraisal shows
less profit than that so in terms of the
idea of of potentially getting more
affordable housing what that would
effectively do is it would start eroding
or it would erode the other
contributions that obviously they've put
to provide so there is the trade-off
that would happen would effectively be
to to lose that uh that that side of
things um just to clarify this point
with regards to the uh the the fold Hill
Point um I understand M's concerns and
obviously um has already outlined um you
know the the concerns on that on that
bit of that stretch of land um in terms
of for example a Gran condition uh
requiring a footpath thing to put in
there's no reasonable Prospect of that
happening at all it's it's under private
ownership in terms of the council
actually uh compulsory purchasing that
land uh that's entirely unreasonable
given that highways don't even object
saying that there's uh you know a
significant and demonstrable impact on
on the movement north to south
especially given the fact that there's a
footpath route that has been secured
throughout previous applications in on
allocated sites in cliffsend and
obviously that secured through this
application in terms of that public
right of way work on on the west so it
would be very I mean it would in our
view be not you know it wouldn't it
wouldn't be a reason for auser that we
would in any way be able to sustain in
terms of a highway objection on
pedestrian safety without the support of
the highway Authority um so that's
that's why obviously what's been looked
at is trying to get the maxim you know
the best possible link through other
means which is obviously what we
consider that that's
occurred thank you councilor
Alban yeah thank you chair
um just to go back on Council byford's
point I think it is a nice
development uh it's laid out very very
very well um but for me it's in the
wrong place and the reason I say that uh
is that uh the report actually says that
the site forms a natural expansion of
the
village uh well we've already had one
extension of the village and now we got
an extension on the
extension uh in in front of us this
evening
um I have to say that um we have have
enough land allocated within the local
plan for development and now were asked
and now we're asked to accept uh a piece
of land that's not within the local plan
uh to put
141 houses on or or houses in Flats
on
um I think that you've already covered
the the point about the
22%
affordable housing
um me included I don't think members
quite understand how that's arrived at
because whatever the uh equation is that
that is used to determine that and from
what I've just heard Mr liit say
effectively it's about cost and it's
about
profitability not about
need so uh that's that slightly annoying
as Council bayford has already uh
said um it's it's quite clear as well
within the conclusion of the officer's
report as it states the land is not
allocated and lies outside the urban
confides within a landscape character
area The Proposal will result in the
loss of this area as agricultural land
and as such there will be a loss the
best and most versatile
land for me that in it that in itself
uh as not being part of the local plan
is a reason to refuse it um so that they
are my uh views chair and I don't think
I could support this application thank
you so just to confirm in terms of the
council or in terms of the allocations
in the local plan you're absolutely
right obviously it's not an allocated
site so when I was outlining earlier
with regards to at the top of the
meeting
um we are as a local Authority in that
paragraph 11 of the mppf world where the
harm has to be demonstrated to outweigh
the benefits that are inherent in the
mppf in that paragraph of providing
housing and because of the housing
delivery test and where we are we are
still in that presumption you know we're
not in a position where we can just
refuse applications because they're not
on allocated housing sites so when
they're outside the open confines um in
terms of you your point about loss of
agricultural land that is a harm um as
you identify um it has been shown
through previous appeal decisions and
the one that members will be familiar
with is the application uh that was uh
in monton for 49 houses where that was
not an allocated housing site uh it was
refused by members twice the first time
it was refused on loss of agricultural
land and in that instance it was best
and most versatile H and it was the
inspector determined that that the
provision of 49 houses when there was an
identified need because of the mppf um
that it was out that it outweighed the
harm to the the loss of agricultural
land so we are having we are taking that
into account when we're balancing up and
obviously now we've made the
recommendation on that basis but I just
wanted to draw memb attention to that
particular appeal decision and how uh
sometimes the inspector can look at it
now this is a larger amount of
agricultural land than in that instance
but at the same time the flip of that is
it's a larger amount of houses provided
as well so just so the members take that
into
account can I just check um when you was
speaking at the beginning of the meeting
you gave a figure of um 71% in the
relevant period um under the old uh
system of 5year housing Supply we will
weigh off um how does the new figures
fit in I think it would help to know um
you talked about the Tilted balance and
also whilst I'm at it um given the
number of developments that are in line
um presumably we've got a reasonable
time scale of when those are are likely
to be completed those that are already
under construction um how will they
affect the
figures um so in terms of the housing
delivery test um the ha Del test takes
three years worth of data um and
basically looks at it over those three
years to work out on the overall
requirement over those years that that's
outlined in the local plan how many hous
have been completed in that time period
now the the statistics themselves which
came out today outline as I say 71% is
where are our percentages of how many
have been completed in that three-year
period and how many were required under
our plan to be delivered in that
three-year period now that requirement
changes during the course of the plan
period and our members will recall me
mentioning this in the training that it
goes up uh to 1,200 a year um in that uh
2022 year which is the last year of
those three years that the current
statistics run the basis of now because
of um the government taking into account
the uh impact that Corona virus had on
the development industry that
requirement overall has been reduced but
we're still at
71% now as time goes on so say we look
at the the next year's wor of the 2023
housing delivery test we've got more
years then that are required for us to
provide 1,200 houses and because of the
the exemption or sorry the reduction
that occurs from that Corona virus
period the statistics do technically get
worse however delivery has increased
over the last few years but not to the
extent that we are providing 1,200
houses a year so the statistics from
October 2022 to October 2023 that I'm
aware of uh put the deliver at about
632 I believe it is houses so it is
unlikely that we are going to in the
housing delivery test going forward
achieve the
75% which was required for us to be able
to say paragraph 11 does not apply to us
uh so it does mean that we are in the
situation where we have to take account
of that the most important policies of
the local plan according to the mppf are
considered to be out of date by virtue
of par
11 and that does mean that that that
Clause that I read out of the start
which is that that actually applications
for housing should be approved um unless
there is demonstrable harm that
outweighs those identified and clear
benefits so members are very familiar
with that test because as you you've all
lived in this world for a while
now thank you uh councilor matterface
next
please thank you we've we' heard an
awful lot about the railway
station um but could ask Mrs fibbs if
you could bring up the overall map with
county bad West on the top and Cliff
sand down at the bottom
please the over they you know your
overall view yeah could you tell me
where the nearest bus stop to this
development is bearing in mind 80% of
all Journeys on public transport are by
BS um it is actually um in Country Road
West right by the entrance to the site
how is that the number nine bus at to
Monon I I I did look at the bus Tim
table um um I mean from what I looked at
it looked like there were buses every
half an hour but I know there's been
some comments from the parish that
there's been some changes to that I
don't know what the current situation is
trust me there have been a lot of
changes to buses and than um the number
nine which used to go to Canterbury and
took people to Canterbury Hospital among
other things now runs less um but less
than once an hour and terminates in
monton it's not really much use if you
want to get anywhere else and also I'd
like to ask you you pointed at Manson
green there'd be a primary school there
but how are people going to get from
this development to that Primary School
when there is no pavement down there's
no proper pavement down cter beo West is
it ask to people to walk along a really
busy road to get to school that there is
a pavement um that runs all the way up
to to the roundabout so all the way
along from here up to the roundabout
then it does stop at the moment to be
fair it does currently stop but that but
through the Manson green application
there will be a continuation of the foot
path so that's why I'm saying you can't
necessarily give I suppose huge weight
in the moment but it is an extent scheme
that's currently under construction so
the expectation is that there would be a
footpath connection that would lead to a
primary school in the future um my next
question is I'm going to ask how far
would it be for people to walk to that
school from this development if they
haven't got
their I have included some estimates in
the report um it's rough because I the
footpath doesn't exist at the moment but
um did I sorry hang on
my yeah so in the report I've I've said
roughly um it would be 20 to 25 minute
walk and a 5 to minute 5 to 10 minute
bike
ride um from from the edge of the
village a 20 minute 25 minute walk for a
mom to walk small children to it would
take a lot longer 20 minutes is
approximately if you fit a mile so it's
it's over a mile to the the proposed
school
yeah we're just going to try and work
that out but yes I I know the 20-minute
mile as
well no way anybody sensible is going to
cycle
that okay while we're doing that I've
got Council of Garner next
please thank you yeah I mean I've I
share the concerns raised by councilors
bayford and Auburn
um about the loss of agricultural land
which is unallocated for housing in the
local
plan and doesn't deliver the 30%
affordable homes as per the policy in
our local plan um and I have I did have
a bit of time on my hands today and I
did start wading through the um
viability assessment reports
of which there are two um and the the
reviews of those
but I was obviously found it very
difficult to make head or tail on in
sense but I just came to the conclusion
actually if we need harms that are not
that are um outweighed by benefits then
they are that is a harm and I I don't
see the benef if this was an allocated
area of land in the local plan like the
shot andan Road one was which those of
us who were here at the time we remember
we came back three times have been lots
of arguments and in the end decided that
actually that was a harm that outweighed
the benefit that it wasn't delivering
the um delivering the affordable housing
and we did refuse and yes it went to
appeal and got overturned but in this
case this isn't land that's allocated
for housing
um one thing that I've read in the
report was the the um the assessment
from the Strategic house housing officer
which I thought was was quite
Illuminating and I don't remember seeing
many many um reports from the Strategic
housing of sorry I've got the um I'm not
talking about the Strate the Strategic
planning manager I beg your pardon I had
to open at the wrong time we don't see
many submissions from the strategic
planning manager and he's basically
saying um that he has concerns with
sustainability of housing development in
Cliff's end especially on non
non-allocated
sites and he's also saying these were
concerns that were expressed during the
local plan review leading up to when the
local plan was was adop adopted and he's
pointed out a couple of um sections from
the inspector's report into the local
plan about Cliff's end saying that sort
of backing up his assessment that this
isn't necessarily an an a sustainable
area for for Housing Development and he
says any assessment of CLI Cliff senders
a sustainable settlement that could
support greater levels of housing will
take place through the local plan review
update process which some of us are part
of and that needs to be done in a con
considered alongside a comprehensive
review and of appropriate range of
services to be delivered alongside any
housing that needs to be in my view I
think that needs to be done before we
consider large developments like this
unallocated land that is also Prime
agricultural land um so that's where I'm
coming from I would I do want to just
add something else based on the really
quite
interesting submission from Network rail
which I found
quite well they've got some nerve to put
it in I thought they they're basically
their F they said their submission
focuses on recently recently open thanck
Parkway which I think at the last
estimate cost uh 4 45 million plus to
develop and I'm not here to argue about
that that's that's been done but they're
saying at present customer facilities at
the station are rather basic and as such
would would benefit from improvements
which is I think why they've asked for
funding for an extra £8,000 9,000 sorry
to put a couple of shelters in I don't
know why they couldn't have spent 45
million. 9,000 it does seem ridiculous I
mean that that is is sort of getting
away from my main points which I think
are this is an un
unsustainable development and so I'm
when unless someone else here who's
going to support it can can persuade me
otherwise then I I won't be
supporting thank you councelor Kean next
please thank you well I like the
community garden and Orchard part of
it but I mean I won't go over all the
points other people have already raised
but it is
unallocated I can't really see how it's
a natural expansion of the village I
think it'll have a huge impact on the
village as it is and its character um
and I also think that you know
developments are supposed to conserve
and enhance the character and I can't
see that this does I'm also worried I
know you'll say I can only consider what
we've got before for us but where we've
got that sort of almost triangular bit
of Green Space
um is is it going to just mean that the
fields behind that are going to be
developed because otherwise I can't see
why that would have been put in there's
other areas of green in the development
but I know you're going to say I can't
consider that yet again we have not the
30% of of um of of uh social housing and
I know you know I've listened to your
explanation but I have yet to see a
development come forward with 30% of of
the affordable housing so I just think
it's very disappoint pointing but for
all those reasons I won't be supporting
this um thanks yeah just to confirm
obviously that as as you identifi
councelor King the application has to be
considered its own merits in terms of
any potential for for future expansion
obiously we have published as part of
the local plan uh review um the the
proposed allocations that have been put
forward which does include the rest of
the land in that sort of section but
indeed the application itself has to be
considered on it on its own just to come
back on the last couple of points about
SP
23 so uh sp23 is the affordable housing
policy it doesn't delineate allocated or
unallocated so it's just any development
for 10 or more units uh and if if
effectively a viability assessment has
demonstrated that the development would
be unviable when meeting those
requirements uh the policy allows for
them to be reduced and that is the
fundamental consideration which came
down in the appeal um because in that
argument it was a even though it's been
demonstrated so they appeared on Shan
Road this is even though it had been
demonstrated that it wasn't viable to
provide more the harm was so great that
it outweighed the benefit um in that
instance that was not considered to be a
a reason to reject the application by
the inspector and so that is why
obviously to your point about 30%
affordable housing I actually think
given the the recent number of schemes
that have come before the committee I do
think actually a lot of them are
providing 30% there are some that it's
more difficult to provide um and in the
instances of some instances and the
shotan road is is actually a good
example because even though the appeal
allowed for 15% because of the way that
funding Works um you can actually get
funding from homes England to provide
over and above what's secured in for in
a section 106 and that development
itself that shaan road development is
bringing forward 66% um so it does
happen obviously we made mention of the
fact of the the development to the north
and also the development in poor H Lane
which is more than the 30% but this
development has Justified 22% there
would be no case to answer a here than
our view and it would you know it would
be an untenable reason for refusal on
that
point thank you I have councelor towning
next
please thank you chair
um going on from where councelor all
been talked about the actual allocation
of um U social housing and the equation
well obviously there's no equation it's
a tradeoff you know you give me this and
I'll give you that and we go forward so
you know it doesn't make a lot of sense
the more important aspect of it is that
we're talking about 144 houses or
properties and of those properties we if
we look at it on the basis of that
there'll be one car per
household or you say 1.5 cars for per
household you're talking about over 200
cars coming into an area that already
has a very limited uh traffic um track
single track isn't that correct I was
told um so that would affect not just
you know you're talking about harm the
harm would be increasing the traffic
increasing the pollution increasing the
envir you know the damage to the
environment so there is a serious harm
here so I mean I can't honestly believe
that we can go ahead with a with a with
a with a development that uh doesn't
have a right to be developed on that
land cuz it Doesn't form part of the
the the the land that has been allocated
for housing so I would not support this
application thank you I do have one
extra question of my own that no one's
asked yet um Street Lighting on the
paths and uh there've been various talks
of paths we've been having a lot of talk
recently about um lighting from the
point of view of protection um of
violence against women and girls
uh what are the proposals for Street
lighting um so in terms of Street
lighting there's no details at the
moment of Street lighting but there's a
condition um for details to come in um
for for the street lighting um that is
mainly to do with the impact on
biodiversity from any bats so usually we
put that condition on for that but it
would also look at genol Street lighting
within the
development um in terms of the air
quality comment just coming back on that
um so they haven't needed to do an air
quality assessment through the
application um because it's not being
considered that there's been a a need
for it but they would have to do a
mitigation assessment and look at the
harm created through the vehicle
movements and use the um damage cost
result from that to put money back into
the development in terms of landscaping
and um sustainable benefits such as the
foot paath links to try and encourage
people to um use sustainable transport
and not use Vehicles so that would be um
again that's conditioned to come in but
the contribution towards the network
rail is part of that as well trying to
again encourage people to use the
railway um and in terms of the vehicle
movements that you just mentioned in
terms of the impact on the highway
because of the fact that road has been
downgraded it's not it's not actually
very well used road anymore because lots
of people use the bypass that goes
around um so in terms of vehicle
movements um KCC haven't raised any
impact on on the vehicle movements that
will go on to Country Road West because
the Junctions um have adequate capacity
to deal with this this um traffic from
the
development and just councilor Mass to
come back on your question about the
distance sorry we haven't forgotten um
it's um looking at it using um using
Google it is
it's a mile uh 23 minutes is what's
estimated for
walking that's qu I found a bit just
been reading through it says there'll be
provision on the application site for
buses to stop that will be good um
discussions will need to be held with KC
public transport on the bus provider to
understand the viability and whether any
Financial contribution is required this
will require access to be suitably wide
enough 6.75 M to accommodate buses but
we haven't heard anything
in Mrs fbn's presentation about any any
buses and I mean at the moment the only
bus is the nine which is a very limited
service so um this is a transport
assessment they're trying to encourage
people not to use their car but they
can't stop using their car if got no
alternative assuming they've even got
one if you're going have a lot of
elderly people and these Bungalows and
chance they may not have
a
are you talk about the comment from
highways or um sorry I don't have
numbers on my page I don't know which
page you're looking
Ator I mean no mention no mention buses
I mean I think there was a mention about
whether could come in to the development
um and obviously that would be something
that the stage coach would have to I'll
presume other companies maybe I don't
know would have to look at for for the
site but in terms of the proximity of
the bus stop to the development because
it is literally sort of to the north by
the axis we wouldn't necessarily be
saying they have to come into the site
because it's still everybody within the
site would be walking distance of the
bus stop um so that wouldn't necessarily
be yeah an issue and I think it was
might have also been mentioned by the um
about by Network R about um a bus link
as well but again it's it probably be
quicker to walk there than get the bus
to be honest from here all the way
around to um to
Parkway okay so I don't have any more
speakers um which means that we will now
put now put the motion for the officer's
recommendation for deferral and delegate
to the vote those in
favor and those against
so the motion is
lost which means we need to have a new
motion I would suggest that it may be
prudent for um a couple of members that
to approach the branch with a short
adjournment to have a discussion before
a new motion is put to
committee that sounds sensible that's
what we'll do who who uh wants to
contribute councelor Oran councelor Kean
councelor G
you yes if any if anyone wants to take a
comfort break at this point um we will
be going into a comfort break at the end
of this debate
anyway
for
e
okay thank you members um we do have an
alternative um proposal uh councelor
Garner would you like to invite Mr
Livingstone yes I would I'd like to
invite Mr Livingstone to read out please
um okay so the the motion that be
proposed would be uh to refuse the
application uh on the basis of of four
reasons for refusal um first one is that
the proposal by virtue of its location
and form would result in the loss of
Countryside and harm to the
characteristics of the landscape
character area and the rural character
of the village where the need for and
the impact of the development has not
been demonstrated to outweigh the need
to protect planet's landscape character
and local distinctiveness with the
unsustainable nature of development in
this location and visual harm resulting
from the additional built form not
sufficiently outweighed by economic
social and environmental benefits
contary to policies spo1 sp24 sp26 and
qo2 of the local plan and paragraphs 8
135 and 138 of the mppf um the second
reason would be that the proposed
development would result in the
irreversible loss of best and most veral
agricultural land
um uh cont to policy uh e16 and
paragraph 180 of the
mppf um with the proposal failing to
demonstrate the benefits of The Proposal
would outweigh the harm arising from the
loss of agricultural land um and then
the third and fourth reason are
technical reasons for refusal because as
members will be aware there is currently
at this point in time no legal
agreement um for actually securing the
contributions for affordable H sorry the
amount of affordable housing on site and
the contributions for development so uh
it would state that third reason would
be the applicants failed to enter into a
legal agreement to secure affordable
housing and the delivery of the
necessary planning obligations required
in order to mitigate the impacts of the
proposed development on local
infrastructure and make the development
acceptable in all other respects the
application is therefore contrary to
policies SP 23 and SP 41 of the local
plan and the mppf and then that the
proposed would result in the increased
recreational pressure on the fet special
protection area and the uh and the trip
SII and in the absence of of an
acceptable form of mitigation to relieve
the pressure uh the proposed development
would cont to policy SP 29 of the local
plan and paragraphs 180 uh and 181 of
the mppf and the habitat
Rags thank you uh councelor gner you for
proposing that yes thank you can I have
a and a second to councelor Kean does
anyone want to ask any questions or
debate that further or shall we go
straight to the vote on that one so
straight to the vote those in
favor and and those
against
abstentions thank you so that is now
carried thank you thank you can I just
can I just ask sorry just to be C can
you tell me what the I could I was
trying to count who what the numbers
were that was all um we don't normally
announce the numbers in this committee
sorry that we we've had that discussion
before and and that was the answer from
um Dem services so thank you um I will
now take a five minute formal break I
know people have taken advantage of the
discussion period
um well you might have apart from me and
and a few others not everyone um but we
will take a f minute adjournment thank
you we have two more um discussion still
to
come
e
for
right I think we're all back in the room
now if we can uh
reconvene
okay all right thank you everyone um
we'll now continue on with agenda item
3B the garage block at the rear of 161
to 213 Clemens Road Ramsgate public
speaking uh speaking in favor of the
application is Mr ree lemon you have
three
minutes thank you chair uh good evening
counselors um I will speak in spot I
will be very brief I'm very aware that
it's a long committee tonight and you
you're stuck with me for the next item
as well so apologies in advance um
someone mentioned earlier this evening
it's it's always quite tricky to speak
in support of something that's you know
already been comprehensively assessed
and written about already um and I I
will be super duper brief just on on
that basis really but I just wanted to
reinforce the the kind of The Wider
overarching ambition of of this item and
and the next one um the scheme before
you draws on a a wider housing delivery
strategy um with TDC as the applicant
who will also be delivering this scheme
this is a scheme based around nine units
here but 49 total units across the
district is part of a affordable housing
delivery strategy uh the first one um
targeting Net Zero for operational
carbon emissions at that um this scheme
in particular breathed new life or would
Breathe new life into an underutilized
part of the existing site making full
use of identified Brownfield land within
Urban confines which as we know already
is is is in clear compliance with
overarching planning policies for the
supply of new housing the new homes
delivered here would be let via the
council housing register and retained as
capital housing stock um they be L at
affordable rent in perpetu subject of
course to any future right to buy
applications that may or may not come in
um interestingly this is a schem I know
we've just spoken on the previous
application about affordable housing and
the 30% this is a 100% affordable
housing scheme um which I'm hopeful that
you agree is a significant benefit of
The Proposal um and likewise in
exceedance of of other policy
requirements eight of these dwellings
would be m42 compliant accessible and
adaptable the other being m43 wheelchair
accessible um I won't talk too much
around matters of design and and
appearance I think your officers have
dealt really well with that in the
report itself but I would again just
emphasize that this is this application
comes forward following preap in Autumn
of last year um and quite an extensive
design Evolution uh in the period since
the submission back in the awesome time
of this year um and great care has been
taken to minimize any sense of
overlooking overbearing nature and so on
and and we really have worked quite hard
with your officers and and Technical
comments that have come in to bring
forward something that is both
deliverable but also something that we
feel is is is appropriate in this
location um there are no outstanding
technical objections on on this
application whether that's from highways
drainage ecology fire and rescue
environmental health and so on uh you'll
have read in the report that there were
some questions raised from the council's
tree officer uh we have worked with
officers to revisit elements of the
proposal and and we are now retaining
the the mature syal tree that was the
subject of that of that query um and we
do agree and the applicant does agree to
a series of related conditions to ensure
to ensure that the protection of that
tree over time um overall your officer
report makes a really clear
recommendation in support of the scheme
and and on behalf of the applicant we do
agree with that and we encourage you to
support that uh we lck support all of
the proposed conditions that have been
put forward um and I will leave it there
thank you very
much thank you I will now hand over to
the planning applications manager to
outline the report
thank you chair so the applications for
the erection of three-story building
containing nine Flats that's four one
bed and five two bed main issues are
principal development impact on
character appearance of the area impact
on living conditions and impact on
highways so the development would occur
following the demolition of some stores
at the rear of um a number of the the
buildings on Clement Road um so we've
got a car parking area that you can see
in the middle of the the picture um so
to the north side got the um it's the
Royal Harbor Academy at this site here
where the field is in the green wedge
between broadstairs and
Ramsgate uh this is an isometric view
from Google just showing that area to
the rear where the proposal would be
cited you can see the bank of trees on
the back of the site so this is a view
looking into the vehicle access into the
site uh with the trees in the back the
sycamore tree that's already been
mentioned is on the left hand side here
so that's proposed to be retained uh the
Landscaping across the back uh is
proposed to be removed with replacement
Landscaping behind uh so we've entered
the site now and we've turned to the
right so you can see the stores that the
majority of which are going to be
demolished as part of the proposal and
you can see that the um the dwellings in
three-story building that wrap around
the the corner to create the courtyard
uh have walkways facing inside uh with
their main entrance doors at the front
with kitchen windows facing into the
courtyard the main habitable room
windows of the bedroom rooms and uh
living areas are either facing the road
or the other way so they don't face into
the site so this is a view looking back
towards that block that we were just
talking I was just talking about and you
can see the stores at the front and the
existing parking areas in the
foreground uh then this is looking again
to that block um there there's a foot
path that runs out and down an Alle way
to the the left hand side to the other
units around the side but this is the
parking area and this is the location of
the proposed
development uh so this is the detail of
that uh Landscaping at the
rear and this is in the back corner
where that footpath is looking back
towards the entrance to the
site and then this is looking just
turned to the left just looking again
that point about the the windows that
are serving the rooms that face into
that
courtyard and then again with uh that
that existing part of the
buildings and then this is looking back
other way so you've got um habit room
windows that are facing into the
courtyard on the on the back of this
property again you can see the sycamore
tree at the back there and then the the
Landscaping on the right hand
side and then this is that uh mention of
that that foot path where we were just
standing and then this is inside that
courtyard with the stores
present so um this is the site location
plan you can see there's an area that's
been that's outside of the uh the sort
of site as we were looking at on the
photos um it's not proposed there's any
development in that area it's that's the
green wedge uh that's just where the
replacement Landscaping is proposed to
go um so this is the existing site
layout
plan uh so you can see that parking the
parking space is at the rear that we
were just seeing the photos of the
stores there and the drying space in the
middle um so the development would be
cited in the parking space uh that was
shown um the existing parking in and
around the area there there are 33
spaces across the whole of the estate at
the moment the development would end up
having 38 spaces so the parking that has
at the moment uh you would be built upon
is being rovided in certain locations in
around where there is existing parking
and then there's a new parking stretch
that's being provided with a new access
road that basically goes where those
stores were so you can see the dotted
lines of the stores that there at the
moment there are 30 stores at the moment
20 22 of them are being demolished to
create the access route and then you've
got a smaller community garden that's
being created in the center of the site
you have a bin storage area in the the
sort of the well I'm going to say the
top Corner in this instance is sort of
the north of the site if we were if we
had put this in the uh Compass
orientation um so just look at in a bit
more detail this is the
existing and then you've got the
proposed here again just showing a bit
more detail of the demolition of the
stores the garden at the front uh the
main entrance to the flats is you know
facing into that community garden you
have um if I go to the the oh sorry this
is these the stores just showing the red
ones to be demolished so you got four on
sorry five on one side and three on the
other side um in terms of the front
elevation of the development so what's
been proposed is a flat roof building um
which has got which is um basically uh
buff brick um you can see on this
elevation that you've got various
recessed panels uh and projecting panels
um that are that are proposed um you've
got side elevations um which similarly
have uh panels that that are basically
showing different articulation so it's
not just a it's not just a box it's got
architectural detailing that's that's in
it as well as already mentioned the aim
of this development is to be um Net Zero
in terms of of carbon uh there is a
condition obviously which is put on all
housing developments which requires
adherence to an equivalent to code level
four this would exceed that requirement
but that's what the policy framework
allows us to require at this point in
time this is the rear elevation so this
is the elevation that obviously has most
of the windows in it that face it out uh
onto uh the green
wedge um then just looking at that floor
plan so internally on ground floor you
have uh a lift so that all of the units
are accessible via lift as well as a
staircase so you have uh the the unit on
the left hand side there that's being
proposed as a wheelchair accessible home
all of the other units are being
provided as adaptable accessible homes
that could be adapted in the future to
wheelchair homes depending on uh
residents needs in due course so they're
looking then at the first floor uh so it
mirrors the layout of the ground floor
and then the uh second
floor which is there and then there's
the roof there so in terms of the
relationship with neighboring properties
the building has been cited to maximize
the distance uh to the units at the
front that you can see at the bottom of
the slide there so you're looking at an
18 M distance from building to building
um as I mentioned the windows that are
actually facing into the side the moment
are not the primary habitable room
windows of those properties so we do
consider that there wouldn't be
significant overlooking created from the
new windows looking into the existing
residence or looking towards the
existing residence similarly with the
relationship with the properties to the
right hand side there's a greater
distance at that point to the neighbors
and in terms of the orientation I
mentioned those buildings that actually
have habitable room windows that face
into the courtyard which is on the left
hand side of the drawing you can see the
orientation of sorry the sighting of
that building at the back is trying to
basically avoid any direct impact to
result in a sense of enclosure to those
windows we do think the development has
successfully achieved that point
all of the units are according with
nationally described space standards and
as I mentioned obviously are being
provided to um an adaptable accessible
requirement uh so just to give you an
idea of the um section through the
building so you've got a parit um which
um in terms of the actual design for the
flat roof um the floored ceiling Heights
you're looking at on this building are
about 2.5 M so they're above the the
required standard what that does though
create is a situation where the building
at the rear which is proposed is
slightly higher than the buildings
around it so one of the things that
we've been looking at is how how does
that sit within the context of the
landscape so this is a section showing
the drying area and the two so basically
we we are standing on Clement's road but
we don't have the building in front of
us and you've got those two blocks
either side um so obviously the
development would be higher than the
development either side but because of
the nature of the openness behind that
development with regards to the green
wedge which obviously cannot be
developed we don't consider that there
is from the development being to the
rear and being higher This Is A View
From The Green wedge so unless you're on
the school field you're not actually
going to see this view um but obviously
it's been cited again predominantly to
avoid the impact on the neighboring
properties around there um and then this
is the side view so Clem road is there
on the right hand side uh and you can
see again that change in height you're
looking at probably just a little bit
probably around about a meter uh above
the ridge height of the existing
buildings um we don't consider that the
design of the flat roof building
particularly conflicts with the
buildings around it obviously the
buildings around it have been built in a
in a particular way in a particular time
uh we do consider that the merits of the
scheme being brought forward including
um the Energy Efficiency of the building
uh and the the the design that is
acceptable in terms of the character of
the area and then sorry the last section
then showing Clement Road is now on your
left and again showing the relationship
but as you see even though it looks like
it it it you know blocks that side of
things obviously the site plan shows
that actually uh you're not having a
direct impact on that neighbor to
Warrant refusal there are obviously
visualizations I say Obviously there are
visualizations that have been provided
uh obviously these are for illustrative
purposes and just the main reason that
I'm showing them members to you is there
is quite a a rigorous Landscaping scheme
that has been put in to try and actually
improve visual amenities of that Central
Courtyard area including planting of
trees HED RS as well as boundary
treatments as well but also the recessed
Windows there and the actual panels
themselves because I think if you look
at a flat elevation I think you'd be
right to be potentially concerned but in
terms of actually what it will look like
because of how it's been designed it
will show you know due regard to Annex
your architectural interest certainly to
to the benefit of the area and then this
is another view just perspective inside
the development uh just showing again
that the detail that's that's provided
um so just in terms of the tree
survey um as I mentioned there is going
to be the L of trees as part of this
development um this is a balanced point
in terms of you losing existing trees
they are category C trees so they aren't
um significant providing significant
immunity value or indeed they they're
not um um you know they are they are
trees that that that are in not
necessarily of a particular age to to
Warrant um higher grade status but the
category B tree which is the Sycamore
will now be retained as part of the
development uh and that has been agreed
by the applicant there are condition
conditions requiring that you can see
from this plan there has been a
provision of you've got five trees
around the back in the area that are
being provided effectively roviding the
trees that are being lost you've also
got a further tree in the back corner as
well as well as the additional
Landscaping to the front so we do think
that there is a certainly a benefit
overall to the amount of landscaping
that's being provided um and just to
pick up um appointment with regards to
the parking KCC have looked at the
transport statement that's been produced
that specifically looked at the amount
of parking in the area as well as the
parking on the spaces within the site
and surrounding parking around there
because you are only looking at a net
increase of of five spaces just to
confirm that's five the report actually
indicates it's six in the paragraph but
just for it's five spaces um however
even though Clement's Road can be a busy
road um and as I'm reliably informed can
be used as as a rat run it is considered
that there is parking available on Road
as well as the fact that you have got
you know there are there are five spaces
on site additional to those that already
provided and the the data that's been
provided and has been agreed by KCC
highways indicates that there is
capacity to avoid harm to highway safety
in the free flow of traffic um now one
one point that I I wish to raise is the
recommendation on this application is is
to defer for approval subject to the
conditions outlined in the report but
also it's for the transfer of the Sam's
contribution now because the council are
the applicant we can't enter into a
legal agreement with ourselves so what
that means is the actual transfer into
the Sam's account has to occur before we
can grant permission that is is not a
regular situation but it is it is
appropriate and has sufficient um record
keeping of probity uh and therefore the
recommendation is to approve subject to
the transfer of of that contribution to
mitigate that and the safeguarding
conditions thank you I'm move that the
officer's recommendation is adopted
would the vice chair please second
seconded thank you do I have anyone
wishing to
speak councelor
bayford thank you chair just to say that
I really welcome this development um
nine self-contained Flats is is really
good to hear and highly sustainable that
to replace the um gges that are unused
at the moment so thank you for
that councilor Kean thank you I also
want to uh support this development I
think it's great but I'm particularly
pleased to see it being next zero and
having the solar panels and things like
that so well done to The
Architects councelor
REI yeah thank you chair i' just like to
um uh concur with my two colleagues
there uh yeah seems like a great little
project and uh wish him
well Council face I'll be very quick no
issue with buses there got short walk to
the loop and no issue with schools got
rooll Harbor behind you and you've got
Dame Janet just up the main road so and
it's a highly sustainable CU you've got
all those shops on on the
um I think that looks like it thank you
for mentioning the rat run because you
know that's my um that was going to be
my question um in that case uh we will
now put the motion for the officer's
recommendation for deferral to the vote
those in
favor and I think that's everyone thank
you so that motion is carried um item 3
C uh site of the form of Dame Valley
arms in Dame Valley Road Margate for
public speaking I have Mr ree lemon
again three minutes perfect thank you
chair um I'll be even quicker on this
one um because the principles are very
much the same it's very much is part of
the same overall project I just wanted
to draw attention to the main point on
this one being that this is this this
site is also an allocated site under
policy
ho1 um for residential use it's it's
described as being purely for
residential use um I really want to to
send to that that's that's come through
quite nicely in in the balancing
exercise of your your officers report um
but I just wanted to draw attention to
that under the obviously adopted plan in
2020 um the site also does benefit from
two previous planning approvals um five
well I think four or five years ago and
and subsequent to that I think about
nine or 10 years ago um including for
resi as part of those applications at
the time but also with with
supplementary mixed juice elements to
those um point being that as I said draw
attention to the 20120 plan and the
allocation of this for unfettered
residential land use rather than a mixed
use um not withstanding that the the
site itself has has been vacant for a
number of years now um it hasn't as far
as we're aware hasn't had a community
use on this it used to of course used to
be a public house that hasn't operated
for at least 10 years it hasn't been
there for about 5 to 7 years um and has
been very much left vacant and and is is
very much the definition of a Brownfield
site and again what we have here is a
100% affordable housing scheme um to be
delivered by the council for its
residents against an identified housing
need um the emphasis really is on is on
implementing this and and and moving
forward and and cracking on with this
and we we've worked hard with with your
offices again informed by preap over you
know Autumn last year I think maybe been
summer last year uh to this point in
time so we have worked quite hard to get
something that we can move forward with
um to to make a genuine difference um
again I won't kind of dive into
character and appearance and things like
that that's dealt with with really well
in the report we have worked quite
closely on matters of overlooking and
overbearing and and those types of
impacts using the previous uh
applications of as reference points as
to what has been approved previously um
and and have come up with a scheme which
we think works quite well and and
pleasingly your officers appear to agree
with that um again similar to the other
application there aren't any outstanding
objections to this proposal um on
technical
grounds um and yes on that basis I yeah
I I would encourage you to support your
officer's recommendation for approval
subject to conditions thanks very
much thank you and over to the planning
applications manager to outline the
report no not quite but
yeah uh this is the site um outlined
here so Arlington Gardens on the left
and Dave Valley Road on and to the
bottom of this
slide um and this is a a view of the
site so um you can see it's it's on the
corner of of uh these two roads opposite
the um open space and and Sh start you
can see in the left of the slide um and
then a closer view of the site so forly
um contained the um D Valley arms Public
House on the site um which as mentioned
closed um between 2009 and 2012 so
hasn't been on the site um as a as a
workable Community facility for a
minimum of 10 years um and then was
demolished in around 200
2016 um and since then the site has has
remained sort of in this
condition um so these are just some
photos quickly of the site so again this
is the um the site um behind this blue
hoarding um and inside the site you can
see the current conditions so it has has
been regularly cleared it's hard surface
mainly previous developed land um and um
in the urban confines you can see
neighboring the site are um Terrace
units and semidetached
units and then just again showing the
conditions of the
land and then this is these are the
properties in Arington um Gardens and
then in Arington Gardens again is here
so there's some level changes you can
see see through the site with um Island
and Gardens um dropping down um so that
the the south of the site is at the
lowest
level and then again just a few more
photos of there so again um we now have
D Valley Road is on the left hand side
here get Arlington Gardens in front of
us and then looking at the exist
existing access point into the site and
then a back at the front and then just
going along to the right hand side just
to show you the properties there so
these are the ex properties to the right
hand side um so you see Terrace units
and you can see the Staggering um
pattern and development of these units
so each block um set in front of the the
one adjacent to it and then this is now
up Arlington Garden so the neighboring
properties of these two uh pairs of
semi- detached units here with the
Dormers at roof level and then just
looking back down the site here so the
proposal is uh for 17 units it includes
four houses and um a block of flats in
this location here um with a new vehicle
access running from um D Valley Road to
create um some parking at the rear but
each of the dwellings also have their
own individual parking space and there's
more um parking to the front of the flat
block um so the one of the main issues
is the
um we have to consider the fact it's a
loss of a community site so um whilst
there's not been a community building on
site for uh for a long period of time
the policy cmo2 looks at the retention
of um Community facilities and it
considers land last previously users a
community facility so even though
there's nothing on the site at the
moment we have to consider that the last
previous use was was as a community
facility so this C has been submitted in
in trying to justify there's not been
any marketing of the site as a community
facility but OB prior to the um Council
purchasing the site um the site had plan
and permission for for housing with a
micro Pub as a replacement of the
community facility that scheme has not
come forward and is now no longer um an
extan consent um and therefore as part
of this submission instead um
justification for the fact there's no
longer a need for this facility has been
put forward so this plan within the
submission looks at the closest public
houses to the site the closest one
probably being um The Hungry Horse which
is 13 minutes walk it's shown on this
plan and then also there's quite a few
public houses within North down Road as
well which is also walking distance of
the site so it is accepted there are um
other facilities that would serve this
catchment um um also through prior to
the application being submitted um a
public consultation was carried out
nothing has been mentioned by residence
about the loss of the community facility
and no one's mentioned through this
application they concerned about the
loss of Comm Community facility either
the site is allocated for housing
there's no um reference in the
allocation policy for the retention of
the community facility so it it's
considered that given the fact there
hasn't been um that facility there for a
while and there is other there are other
facilities is in walking distance of the
site and the fact that doesn't seem to
be a concern by residents that actually
the the loss of that facility is is
potentially um Justified if the benefits
of the scheme are are considered to
outweigh that so um again just looking
then at the elevations so there's block
a which is the semi- detached here Block
B here and Block C here so these are
block a the two semi- detached
properties front arlingon Gardens um
with a a double um Bay projection um
just two stories ease level with um
again solar panel at roof level um and
then the rear elevation of these and the
sides and then just the uh ground floor
um layout and first floor level so the
three bed
units and then for the Block C which is
um front in D Valley Road Again similar
design units you can see there that's a
rear elevation and the S so you can see
these are staggered so similar to um
those blocks next door that I showed you
these are also staggered following that
pattern of development
um and that's the first FL of that one
and then in terms of the flat block this
is the flat block so it is a much larger
dominant building but we have privacy
approved three story on the site um on
the basis that it was quite a large
building that was there originally it's
on the lowest ground level um it's a
corner and it feels like something quite
um dominant could work on the corner and
quite nearby we've got lots of um three
story flat blocks um that affordable
units owned by the council that are in
close proximity so it's not completely
out of character the area to have
buildings of this scale um so this is
the um elevation frontting onto
Arlington
Gardens um and then this is the
elevation fronting onto DNE Valley road
so it does go slightly higher here with
an actual four um fourth story element
this bit set back a little bit further
these are all staggered elements so in
terms of the bulk of the building whilst
it is quite large it's really broken up
by these three different elements that
you can see that are gabled from the
side and are staggered um from um from
that elevation as well um and then this
is the internal um elevation facing in
towards the access road um so again
there is slightly higher but the ease
level is a bit lower and the the windows
are actually set within the roof space
quite large um Windows floor to ceiling
Windows which help to break it up and
again similar to the um design you saw
before these are all recess windows and
there's lots of brick detailing within
the um elevation as well and you can see
there's two different types of brick as
well which also help to break it up um
and then that's the uh um elevation
facing the north um so just floor plan
so internally there's a refuge store in
that far top corner with a cycle storage
so that was originally um facing um the
side Alleyway but um the Wast and
recycling team said they would prefer to
see it at the rear so that they can
reverse vehicles in and collect from the
back which so that's now been addressed
um there and then this is just the first
floor so you can see there's four four
flats per floor and then the second
floor and then the the ones at the rear
in that fourth floor um or third floor
element and this is the street
elevations so you can see the top one is
showing arlingon Gardens you can see the
existing two story dwellings and then
the proposed dwellings and then this
flat
block and then the bottom one is is onto
Dame Valley Road so again the the units
closest to the neighbors are similar in
um scow and and design and then it's
just this one on the corner that's
slightly larger and then these are the
uh visuals showing how this could look
so again you can see here the the re
recess the red brick um gray
Windows um and then on this bit element
here this Central section set back so
again help help create some sort of
Staggering in that front
elevation and then that's a view from um
D Valley Road so again Landscaping is
been introduced which isn't previously
hasn't previously been on the site so
there's going to be some tree planting
along um the front hedge
rows and then the access point um is in
this point here that's just showing the
brick and uh material
details
so um in terms of impact on neighbors
there's not really any huge impacts on
neighbors the closest property here in
Block C does um just for outside the 45
degree line so doesn't impact on number
182 um 182 raised concerns with the
boundary treatment along here that's
looking to be removed as a brick wall
and then rebuilt up to 2 MERS um so that
should um prevent any any impact on that
neighbor from a a new wall being along
there these properties just follow the
building lines of the other properties
so the only real concern was whether it
was overlooking from any of the units
there's 21 M from the flat block to the
nearest property here um there could be
some Overlook into the actual propos
units themselves from the from the
windows in the flat blocks so all of the
lower half of the windows have been
obscure glazed to make sure there's a
limited overlooking um but otherwise
there not considered to be any real real
impact highways have raised no concerns
with it there's one parking space per
unit plus an additional one parking
space um the uh parking um the road has
visibility displays and electric vehicle
charging being provided in terms of
doorstep play Space each of the
properties have Gardens there's it's
quite tight in trying to um get space
for the doep play space but this area
here to the side of the flats is being
provided um as doep play Space um so the
the only other issue is uh Financial
contributions so obviously 100%
affordable housing is being achieved on
the site um but contributions because of
it being a major application have been
requested um by KCC for for um for other
other things um out
infrastructure um we've been able to
secure all of the contributions other
than the secondary school contribution
um the the development is quite tight in
terms of funding uh it's a not not
for-profit scheme because of the fact
it's a council um scheme where we're
looking to achieve this 100% affordable
housing so to to provide the secondary
education contribution would um cause um
concerns with um the funding and would
delay the time in which we break even
the council break even with the
development and we end up with money
coming back into the housing um um
allocation funds for future um Housing
Development there's a a point of 30
years that if it goes beyond that it
becomes too risky for the council to
proceed with and it's no longer viable
if we proceed with the secondary school
contribution it would take it close to
that point um and and obiously what we
want to see is is something come forward
in this site I think residents are Keen
to see the site enhanced and obviously
we're keen to see um the 400% affordable
housing on the site as well um so on
balance it it was considered that it's
it's reasonable not to um secure the
second G um contribution on the basis
that there are other benefits of the
scheme that would um outweigh that that
particular harm so it is recommended to
be um deferred for approval again
subject to us securing the financial
contributions within our section
106 account I don't know it's called in
the planed forign so thank
you thank you I move that the office's
recommendation is adopted with the vice
chair please second seconded thank you
um anyone wish to
speak councelor
Boyd this was my first site visit a few
days after I had been elected as award
counselor for danne Valley and I was
terrified that it was just going to be
be too big and and not enough space but
when I was shown around the site and the
drawings and it's like wow they really
have have thought of everything so so
carbon neutral wow um there is drying
space there's heat pumps there's solar
panels it it just is an
incredible regeneration of Dame Valley
Dame Valley doesn't have a lot of money
spent on it and this is for me is just a
win-win thank you anyone
else in which case uh we will now put
the motion for the officer's
recommendation for deferral and delegate
to the vote all in favor that's carried
thank
you which then brings me to the say that
this concludes the business for this
meeting thank you for your attendance
good night season's greetings see you
next year good night Merry Christmas
CH and we didn't quite make the half 10
need to do an
extension